[Laughter]
hey
everybody it's friday night hopefully
you guys can hear me because it's a good
thing i noticed and i've tried to check
like every time now but sometimes
i open obs and for some reason it
doesn't turn the microphone off but
right here where it says device
like where your audio device is it'll be
like no device and i'll just be like uh
there is a device it's right there but
for whatever reason because i just made
a video earlier like i recorded it and
that came out okay but when i opened it
up again
it was off so hopefully you guys can
hear me yeah i guess they could hear
they'd be they'd be saying no sir they'd
be saying no sound by now i would think
so hey everybody what's going on it's
friday friday we're gonna have a little
chat and have a few drinks uh before we
go out we gotta go out of the club
tonight yeah
so i have to remain
relatively sane because i gotta drive
yeah so i mean like i said we
technically don't have to leave until 9
30
so we have i mean i'm not saying we can
stay until 9 30. i'm just saying that we
don't have to like
if we go off then we can like [ __ ]
get ready i'm mostly ready i have makeup
on and stuff i could like
but i already know what i'm gonna wear
and [ __ ] like that the thing is is the
longer i'm on this show the more i'm
drinking i told you though you have to
like exercise some restraint i don't
want you like go like going all like ape
and out like you sometimes do
and like and like shout it and
jumping up and down like donkey kong
yeah
oh honky kong comes back honky [ __ ] yeah
or the abdominals you know yeah the
abdominals what was the other one that i
made up [ __ ] hockey car i mean that
was the best
the abdominal snowman
i still want to make a honky kong
t-shirt like with you but like pixelated
vanilla gorilla oh that's right
[Laughter]
those probably already exist anyway i'm
sure they do but it's like it would be
funnier if it was like you if i could if
i you know could get back into like
drawing like i used to yeah i could do
like a cartoon of you looking like a
gorilla like yeah for another gorilla
that would be super funny danny rowling
said tom what's the top speed on your
new lawnmower uh probably it's probably
only about 10.
it goes slow
no wonder it takes such a long time
no you can't go fast anyway under that
uneven ground well yeah and i got a i
got a damn um
uh and i'm not even going 10 i'm
probably going
three or five
because you have to uh get up close to
fences and go around to obstacles and
you know what the [ __ ] was that about
and then um computer over here screw it
off it's not it's just like went off i
went to sleep it's a good mower though
it's a husqvarna
ride not orange
i'm riding that thing like that i got my
[ __ ] hat cocked back like i'm a
farmer
people driving by waving
dudes [ __ ] give me thumbs up that's a
good mower it says yeah i know i got a
good moment not a lot going on in this
neighborhood as you can tell
look that guy's mowing look yeah yeah
well i've noticed that dudes are [ __ ]
sporting what whatever kind of mower
they have you know they got those john
deere mowers they're green see
the the john deere ones are green
and then um the other ones were red i
forgot i forgot what what the what brand
that was
they were well they are the honda ones
red
i probably probably are but that's not
the ones i was seeing i'm trying to
remember what it was i know what you're
talking about but i can't i can't think
about it craftsman yeah there you go
craftsman they're the red ones
and then um
i got the orange one
yeah i got the orange one that's
obviously the best yeah i got the orange
one it's got headlights on it
i think most of them do now yeah they
organize them ladies and gentlemen all
the elections deluxe was due yeah it's
deluxe lady vesuvius says you totally
suit the blue hair johnny thank you very
much
yeah i'm this is like i said i've been
buying lots of lots of wigs but of all
the of all the colors that i bought i
like the blue one the best
yeah and i think the red one's my second
favorite but
i like them so much that i actually
bought two of these that are exactly the
same and i have one that's like a darker
blue that's a little bit wavy which i
don't quite like as much but i think
blue looks nice thank you very much
thank you very much next dimension media
hey guys got my t-shirt this week looks
awesome i wore it during a business soup
call this morning oh cool yeah some send
some like advertising out there yeah
thank you i forgot which one i sent to
him it was i think it was snake pliskin
i think there were two other two of them
right yeah and then uh yes that that's
good there's a tank snake pliskin and
probably a uh
a cannon
cannon films
yeah that's right we'll wait
yeah i think it was a canon film yeah it
might have been i can't remember now
either
zach says hey y'all saw your blowout
review this morning and yes i was
excited uh i thought you would be uh
that shot at the end of travolta holding
nancy with the fireworks in the
background is so beautiful yeah it
really is and speaking of brian de palma
movies
a friend of the show
louie
sent us just today yeah check this out
steel book edition of the untouchables
right
i love that cover to be honest yeah i
don't know if he's i don't know if he's
in the uh in the livestream i don't know
i don't usually see him in the live chat
unless he's lurking and not talking but
it's like if you're out there louis
thank you very much because i haven't
seen this movie for years and years ago
louie just sends me awesome movies yeah
i've already seen him before i haven't
seen him in a long time we'll do it
we'll review it but some of my favorite
movies were movies that louie sent me
yeah we actually maybe we'll watch it um
like tomorrow night and then we can talk
about it on sunday yeah good taste i
mean he'll show me some [ __ ] i've never
seen before and i was like oh yeah that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] classic he earned my
respect with pain and gay and he sent me
that one yeah i was like oh this dude
here [ __ ]
and he tried to kept getting me to see
collateral he said it to me and we
couldn't get past the first five or ten
minutes of collateral then i got past
[ __ ] collateral collateral was a
badass flick
yeah it's one of those ones that like we
just had to be patient you got to be a
little bit patient and then like all of
a sudden you find out tom you realize
that tom cruise is in this movie and
he's an assassin and he's a dick but
he's kind of cool
and then
tom cruise plays a good villain
you know he's
i know he doesn't like that but you know
he likes to be heroes all the time and
[ __ ] [ __ ] boring he's like a mary sue
you know
but uh
be a bad guy embrace it yeah his
villains are a lot better
they are i like him as a stock a lot of
people didn't like it was the stuff but
i like the business dad
richard the hutt says uh hey jenny did
you get a chance to check out heaven
falls hard i did i listened to it this
morning and that is uh quite awesome so
thanks for recommending that because i
had actually
never heard of that before uh which you
know so that's cool i always like new
stuff but yeah i really liked that a lot
to be honest with you uh zach says uh
connery's oscar win yeah that's right
what i love about de palma's movies is
how much fun he has with filmmaking as a
medium i just wish he put as much
attention into his writing as his images
well you know you can't have everything
you can't ever
uh zak said the films he writes himself
usually almost always make no sense
yeah tom cruise does play a good villain
says john smith his best role to my mind
is lestat yeah i've always liked him
more and i know we've had this
discussion before but i've always liked
him a lot more like when he's playing a
bad guy
like
or when he's playing just like a
[ __ ] or like an [ __ ] you know
what i mean
but she doesn't do all that much
jack torrance says i'm back uh-oh please
don't hit me with a rope mallet
[Laughter]
i liked him as lost i liked him in
collateral is that uh is that assassin
he was pretty good in that science
fiction movie where he played a clone
that was what was that name what was
that one
wasn't there one called oblivion
oblivion yeah
it turned out he was a clone of himself
and there was a lot of them
and that the earth had been taken over
by he thought by aliens
like we don't need more tom cruise yeah
okay i'm just saying
but like you've seen that in a while
i don't think the earth was taken over
by aliens they told him he thought it
was turned out the aliens were actually
humans
he was working for a uh
a super computer or something wouldn't
it
i don't remember
like i remember liking that movie but i
don't really remember
what happened it didn't make like a huge
impression
but um
yeah well okay so are they making a new
interview with the vampire like a movie
or a series because
in my youtube feed like a thing came up
that was like a new trailer drop and i
haven't and i didn't get a chance to
watch it yet but i was like wait are
they make are they remaking interview
with the vampire they're gonna do it
kind of oh it'd be [ __ ] up they can't
make that now well i don't know like the
thing about i don't know if it's a
series i don't know what it is
so
yeah i don't think they'd be able to
make that well i'm not going to like
[ __ ] through the projects like before
i've even seen it i don't even know what
it is like i said i just saw like a
trailer they would have they would i
would have to uh see who was involved in
it who was making it
you know who was directing and writing
it and
because uh
no
depending on who you give that to they
will [ __ ] that up
well the thing about it though
is that
i feel like nowadays
if you're gonna make a project like that
i think the people that are going into
it are kind of like well we have to do
this right or
everyone's gonna [ __ ] you know what i
mean like something like that that's so
iconic
no i mean not always but it's just kind
of like it does seem like they at least
try to put some like thought into it you
know i think you're overestimating who's
out there they're they're [ __ ] crazy
look what they did to the new uh lord of
the rings so everybody says that that's
a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] um they're just
they'll take anything that has a an
iconic name and just uh [ __ ] it up you
know john smith said there's an upcoming
vampire chronicles tv show oh okay well
like i said i always thought it'd be
better as a series because yeah it's
like really complicated well that if it
was vampire chronicles and that means
they'd have to cover all the books which
where do they start how what order are
they gonna tell things in they gotta
[ __ ] that up
that's the spirit yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] that up
there's enough talent out there to do
those books he says that about
everything and then like later on like
some stuff will come up and it's really
good and he'll forget that's why that's
why i'm never [ __ ] disappointed
because i already the starting point is
no it's it's going to be [ __ ] up
because it usually is
but if it has talented people writing it
and acting in it you'll know you'll know
through the pr campaign if the pr
campaign is [ __ ] crack of [ __ ] you'll
know you'll know
i'm not worried about it yeah i just
didn't know because like i said i just
saw the trailer come up and i didn't
have a chance to watch the trailer but i
was just kind of like oh i guess they're
making a new one but like i said i don't
mind that because as much as i liked the
1994 movie i was like it would have been
nice if they would have actually like
back then made the whole trilogy that
would have been neat um instead of doing
interview with the vampire and then
doing queen of the damned which was kind
of like queen of the damn vampire lestat
and everything was like crap like two
big giant novels were crammed into one
movie and it wasn't real it wasn't as
bad as i remembered but it's still not
that good so i kind of wish that they
had taken more time
unfolding the story so i you know i
think a series is probably the best way
to go with that kind of stuff because
although re-watching queen of the damned
it wasn't as bad as i remembered it well
i just said that yeah it was it was
still not good but
i wouldn't say
i wouldn't uh it was it was good it was
good but just good
just it was just it was okay
it was just a dumb idea
to try and cram both of those giant
books into one movie like why on earth
would you do that i don't know why you
would do that
you shouldn't make a brother well i
think a lot of it was to make a buck on
[ __ ] movie soundtracks
well yeah badass album came from it i
had that album i liked it it had a lot
of good songs for like new metal type
goth
it was like new metal
songs yeah
which they're pretty good you know um
but
certain aspects of the movie they got
right and then a lot of it they got
wrong
it's it's just real hard to do and rice
stuff and i don't think they can do it
because
anne rice
from today's point of view would be
extremely [ __ ] unwoke
and i don't think they would allow it
they would have to [ __ ] locify it and
then it would
be [ __ ] up because it was subversive
it was subversives they were subversive
books to begin with even back when they
came out
and uh
they wouldn't like that i mean
the scott ate black dudes
he'd go he would go to the [ __ ] hood
to just eat black dudes he said you like
he
he said that [ __ ] nobody nobody
noticed when they went up when they came
up missing and [ __ ] there was a lot of a
lot of aspects about that book today
wouldn't fly
but the thing about it is like that
that's just not her i mean that's her
commenting on
that's nothing that's not racist or
anything like that it's just true
i mean yeah but in the mindset of
[ __ ] uh of filmmakers today they
can't even they can't even think like
that they uh they they would have to
reverse all that
um it was just no
no i i don't i wouldn't trust him you'd
have to have a real talented crew to to
tell that story and to tell it
accurately
with the same kind of
same same kind of panache that the
[ __ ] books had
and they would see it as a glorification
of all that stuff so they couldn't
they couldn't i don't think they could
tell that story
and just you know not not well
it would be a piece of [ __ ]
they would make it real lukewarm
and real blah
and that's that's what they would do
with it they would think it was great
though
it would be it would be all [ __ ]
stunning and brave and [ __ ] but there's
just nothing there
zach said lost a lot of respect for anne
rice after learning how she handled fan
fiction of her work which don't get me
wrong fanfics can be toxic as [ __ ] yeah
i get that but
yeah i had her she seemed like an okay
person overall but yeah she didn't
really like people writing a fanfic of
her stuff which is i mean it's not like
you know nobody if you write fan fiction
that's you're not selling it you're not
kind of like jumping off
you know
riding their coattails a lot of people
just write it like like zack said like
for practice
so
because they like the characters so as
long as you're not making money off it i
don't see what the issue is
uh yeah john smith said queen of the
damn starring stuart whatever happened
to him townsend was he actually in any
other movies or no that guy yeah i
haven't seen that guy since huh i mean
i'm sure he must have been in some other
things but
i don't know if he's i mean he was okay
in that movie but he was bad but like i
said it not it wasn't like terrible but
it just didn't really make an impression
and it was just like i said it was a
stupid idea to start with like to
cranberry there's a lot of [ __ ] about
interview the vampire that was [ __ ]
i don't know if it translates well
just to the screen i mean if i remember
correctly
i think my stop was turned into a
vampire at what 16. so he looked like a
16 year old always did he i thought he
was 18 18 16 okay i mean it's been a
long time since i've read the empire
chronicles but i thought i thought he
was eighteen or nine i think how
ridiculous that would actually look on
camera
well that's what i'm saying and we
talked about that a lot particularly in
regards to stephen king is that like
you know i'm not
if you're making a movie out of a book
it doesn't have to be exactly like the
book because [ __ ] that works in a book
doesn't work in a movie like you just
have to know like what things to change
and what things you know as long as you
get like the spirit of the [ __ ] it's
fine right you have a 18 year old
[ __ ] what appears to be an 18 year
old boy and in a suit with all this
money
with an army of lawyers [ __ ] handling
all this business and and he's a rock
star
and he rides around on a harley davidson
and down in new orleans it's just you
know
i mean and then he intimidates people
and it it which which you know what i
mean it's just well they really have to
get the right actor for that i mean
obviously they couldn't get somebody
that looked like an 18 year old like it
like a gawky high school yeah but i've
seen some 18 year olds that looked like
adults or like looked like people in
their 20s i went to high school with
some kids yeah it looked like they were
old yeah so you could totally pull it
off yeah but the only ones that could do
what and to do what he's being described
doing and getting away with in a social
situation would be like
[ __ ] dudes are doing cycles of
steroids and [ __ ]
you know even though he's not described
as being very big
but a lot of those guys that looked
adult were [ __ ] and asked
but again i know the dudes that we went
to high school with
were
dave kennington we're huge six foot two
first time watching live welcome who's
this uh dave kennington keep doing what
you're doing guys by the way speaking of
vampire films have you seen steak land
i've seen it yeah uh yeah it's actually
really good i haven't seen wasn't there
a sequel i didn't see that but the first
one's actually really good so it was
like under underrated classic yes it is
i agree rebecca says hi folks feels like
forever since i got to be here during
the majority of a live show happening
finally yeah because i think
didn't you come like wednesday night and
it was like right when we were signing
off like after three and a half hours or
something like that
um
let's see anne haiti died yeah she did
um
yeah she was the one she was uh married
to ellen degeneres
she was in a car wreck wasn't she was it
a car wreck and then she was in a coma
for a little while okay i didn't know
about that um john smith said stuart
townsend was the original choice to play
aragorn in lord of the rings they
replaced him at the last moment because
he was a massive bell-end
it's like a like a [ __ ] or like an
[ __ ] yeah
that's one of my favorite british terms
um seems when townsend and charlize
theron broke up he disappeared
yeah maybe she was the one like getting
them some rolls oh that's where i'd seen
him before okay i knew i'd seen him in
moves lee warner said he played oscar
wilde in league of extraordinary
gentlemen okay i knew i'd seen him in at
least one other movie i don't remember
much of that movie but i do kind of now
that you say that
uh tom holland would probably make a
good list at maybe i don't know
i don't really know
i don't know
i don't know like
of all the youngsters that are out there
the youngsters
the utes i don't i don't know like which
one of them i'm sure there's got to be
one
and let's see
best timing ever the chick from the
psycho remake yeah yeah ann hitch was in
the show i mean she wasn't a bunch of
other stuff too but
and that was another let's talk about
that like the [ __ ] psycho remakes did
you just see that it was gus van sant
right like directed it how did you see
it
well you you didn't miss anything it was
completely pointless because it was a
shot for shot remake of the original
psycho so why except well that's what
everyone said when it came out there's
like and what was the point of that
again
like why would you
like you know remaking psycho
was
i mean from the jump was probably like a
stupid idea but then if you're gonna do
that if you must
why make it exactly the same except
modern and in color dumb they'd be like
remaking gone with the wind like why
like why would you do that
strangely no one has remade gone with
the wind have they it's boring
well yeah but well that's well that's
more of an argument to remake it maybe
somebody can make it more exciting
that's like some [ __ ] your grandma watch
let's look at let's add some car chase
yeah
yeah some anatomy
yeah an explosion
[Laughter]
well i mean the house burns down at the
end that's that's exciting
oh my god
yeah john smith said uh anne rice's
choice for lestat was rucker howard yeah
that was who she was thinking of like
when she uh wrote the character
so
i yeah i mean i could see that and you
know she wrote it so i'm not going to
argue with her but i will i always
pictured somebody not i mean i love
rucker howard he's rad but it's just
kind of like i always pictured somebody
not so
i pictured somebody more like graceful
more like a ballet dancer or something
like that it's homosexual vampire porn
well yeah that's what that was it was
her sexual fantasies i didn't really
like picture somebody as kind of like
gruff and yeah kind of bulky as
ruckerhower i pictured somebody more
that's what i thought
yeah
i was thinking you know
i don't know what i was thinking
back in the old days back in the 80s and
90s i thought that peter murphy would be
good
like when he was blonde remember when he
went back when he was good looking back
when he was good looking like before the
meth took over
like when and particularly like in 1990
when deep when his album deep came out
like when he had that white blonde hair
yeah and like i actually saw him live
then
and i always thought he would make a
great list at back then like if they had
made it back then he would have been a
great list at that's who i pictured or
the joker
yeah now i haven't seen him in a long
time i don't know what he looks like
nowadays
didn't bauhaus just get together again
and like tour again recently it looks
like he did when we saw him last time we
saw him it looks just like that worse
more pot bailey
more pot belly he's got a pot belly yeah
low tea [ __ ]
although the weird thing is that i think
i'd the other day i saw um
david jay and he looks almost exactly
the same yeah i probably took care of
myself better i mean that [ __ ] never
seems to age
those real hard drugs like that can
[ __ ] just wreak havoc on on a human
body i mean
[ __ ]
look at some of them girls out there
[ __ ] selling themselves they're
[ __ ] 22 and they look like they're
[ __ ] 62.
the meth just [ __ ] eats them up
just like i saw rebecca's comment i just
laughed she said the point of the psycho
remake was just to put vega mortensen in
front of me to get inappropriately
turned on in a cinema full of strangers
i totally forgot vegan mortensen was in
that i only saw it one time because i
felt like i had to and then i was like i
saw it and i was just kind of like
okay gus van sant i don't really see
what it just seemed like a stunt
david's here what's up dave you going
out tonight
yeah it's memento mori yeah well he's
probably going to mannequin yeah imagine
where can i go to memento mori
at barbarella have you seen the new
sandman series i have not
not yet
uh actor brother theodore aka uncle
reuben from the burbs could have played
lestat
um
i guess yeah
maybe
he was a little old though well see that
was another thing too like by the time
they got around to making the interview
with the vampire movie ruckerhour was
probably a little bit too old because
like you said in the book
lestat is young i mean he was turned
when he was like a teenager or like
early i want to say he was 18. i think
he was eight yeah maybe i thought it was
like like 16 but
i mean it could have been yeah like i
said it's been ages since i've read it i
haven't read it a long time but i was
like i was kind of like that young how
could he he's he's that young and how
could he
look in that you know i just you know
figured that that look awful strange
but you know they weren't living in
society
yeah
well and they were also supernatural
beings so
i mean
yeah human stuff didn't apply they were
yeah they were real anxious
but they did they didn't really have to
interact with anybody they they they
would
just you know we need to read the book
because they they could interact with
people they didn't have to
they uh they had people doing stuff for
them lawyers and [ __ ]
depend on how much money they had steal
people's houses by turning them into
vampires
you know it was where anne rice got that
from [ __ ]
scream back of the screen
yeah i just talked about that on one of
my videos that i put up the other day
dave says not sure where i'm going
well
if you go to barbarella we'll see you
there because we're going
to memento tonight yeah
and somebody was talking about oh
they're talking about the remake of
nosferatu
yeah without the one with klaus kinski
right the one with the
the poster that i have back on that yeah
well they made like a um they made a
sequel to that too like crybaby brings
it up nosferatu and venice 1988.
she said that also had klaus kinskin in
it it was good we're just talking about
class kinsey though hey creepy
[ __ ]
he said he should always play like
[ __ ] monsters and [ __ ] like that i
see that one i don't think i saw that
one i don't remember seeing that one
either i mean we saw
the first one obviously the nosferatu
remake but
you know what i mean
yeah right yeah you seem like you're
kind of like facing out yeah a little
bit sleepy why are you sleepy mm-hmm i
woke up early
um was it what time was it
about eight oh
i woke up at 6 30. yeah look at about
eight
yeah but i went to sleep about
two i fell asleep at like 10 30 or 11
but i woke up a couple of times
um
[Music]
guama khan says fitting you guys are
talking about remakes and right next to
that nosferatu poster is the superior
2018 one yeah honestly i really liked um
i'm gonna say this right now obviously i
really i like the original suspiria it's
one of my favorite horror movies ever
um but i did actually really like the
remake
and to be honest with you
i like that poster
better than the original suspiria poster
because i kind of wanted an original
suspiria poster but
the official suspiria poster is kind of
boring now there have been like some
really beautiful ones that like artists
have made like i have like a whole
folder full of pictures of ones that
different graphic designers and stuff
made like over the years and you can buy
those as posters but usually they're
limited edition and they're really
expensive so i wouldn't mind like having
one of those but
the official poster for suspiria is like
not that exciting
you know
i mean considering how [ __ ] cool and
like visually iconic that movie is more
ice
yeah they could have done like a better
poster than that and to be honest like
right there like right you can't see it
but it's because it's like on that wall
but i have a poster for
uh another dario argento movie profondo
rosso
and it's another one where
i like the movie a lot but like the
poster is not really that exciting i
mean the poster kind of looks a little
bit like the one for vertigo to be
honest
so
i'm really into like poster art man and
it's really it really like it hurts my
little graphic design heart when
there's like it's really really super
awesome movie and like the poster is
just kind of like man
you know what i mean i'm like makeup and
good co-poster man that's why i was like
so excited when i saw the cover of this
like untouchables here right here
because i was like oh look at that i
love that [ __ ] cover that's so cool
thank you thank you thank you guamo khan
just sending a little gift to y'all
because it's deserved thank you very
much thank you
uh john smith said
saspiri was the first argento movie i
ever saw it blew my mind yeah i don't
know it might have been the first one i
saw too now that i'm thinking about it i
mean it was the first one that i was
kind of like aware that it was like
dario argento you know what i mean
um
don the bomb said just showed my mrs wes
craven's people under the stairs she
thought it was great fun yeah that is a
really fun movie and a little bit
underrated i feel like
i thought i heard they were remaking
that too but i guess they never got
around to it
uh guama khan said suspiria 2018 is my
favorite depiction of magic and witch
[ __ ] yeah i really liked and i think
that i said even before i knew that they
were remaking suspiria
um i was like man how would you even
remake that because it's like if it
doesn't look the same like visually then
it's not suspiria but then like you
change it to but you know what i mean
it's just like i was like i don't
understand what the point of it but then
like when they remade it and i went to
see it he went like in a completely
different direction with it and even the
story i mean the story was similar but
um you know it was the spirit of the
story was the same but he like changed
pretty much everything else about it and
i think like in hindsight that was
probably the best way to go because i
think if you're gonna like
make it
too much like the original with like the
visual style and everything like that
people just be like well what was the
point of that because you're just like
ripping off dario argento's movie
so
that was really kind of like the only
way so i liked it like a lot more than i
thought i would because that was one of
the movies that i was like oh they
should never remake that one because
what would be the point of it but
you know what i mean
um ever seen santa sangre yes actually i
did a review of that
i can't remember if i did a review of it
on my flickers of fear series or if we
did a movie retrospective of it we might
have done a movie retrospective of it
because i think i remember tom being
like this is the weirdest [ __ ] movie
ever
but
i remember i saw it a long time ago like
because me
and a bunch of my friends in high school
we were all like the weirdo
like gotham kids and we were super super
into like weird [ __ ] movies like and
this is like late 80s early 90s so it's
much harder like uh to see a lot of
these movies it's not like now where you
can just like get them on streaming or
whatever and
we lived in daytona beach so the
theaters we had a couple movie theaters
we had like a nice one and then like a
dollar one
and you know art films and stuff like
they don't really ever play there so if
there was a movie that you wanted to see
that was kind of like an art film you
always had to wait like a year or two
like until it came out on video and then
maybe the video store would have it but
a lot of times not
so it was kind of a pain in the ass and
then there was kind of like for a little
while
there was like this little play it
wasn't even a movie theater really but
it was just like this little it was like
a little coffee shop and then they had
like a back room that had like a little
bit of like a janky theater like set up
back there and they would show
you know art films and documentaries and
stuff like that like once a week for
like a couple of bucks so and it was
only you know it was like less than a
mile from my house so sometimes i would
like ride my bike down there and like go
watch movies and stuff during the day
but so it was really hard to see stuff
but santa's sangro was one of the movies
that
i think either we either rented it or
i've saw it on cable
because i remember everybody saying like
you have to see this weird [ __ ] movie
and i think i probably watched it at my
friend's house because we used to like
rent weird ass movies all the time and a
lot of times i'd rent them and then like
back in the old days when you had the
the dual deck vcrs and you would rent
movies and then you'd like you know make
a copy of it if it didn't have macro
vision protection on there but you could
there was ways to get around that
because they used to have a thing where
they wouldn't let you tape it
but you could find out
how to get around it
um
dave kennington says uh phenomena was my
first argento that was a weird one i did
a review of that one too amazing film
with that chimp didn't win best
supporting actor that year the oscars
are out of balls
what a weird uh premise that movie was i
just rewatched it like i said cause i
did a review of it for flickers of fear
not too long ago and i said god i forgot
how [ __ ] strange this [ __ ] movie
was
it's almost kind of like two movies
like squished together it's like a
giallo movie kind of but then it's also
like this really weird paranormal
movie about a girl that can like
psychically communicate with insects
jennifer connolly's in it and donald
pleasance is in it and also there's a
chimp in it and there's a bunch of
insects and she can like
it's crazy it's it's a weird weird movie
john smith said uh i know they had to
change jennifer connolly's character's
name to jennifer so the chimp didn't
freak out and rip her face off
that's not funny because they actually
will rip your face off but
um
yeah
okay just the premise sounds awesome of
what a phenomena or of uh santa sangria
because santa sangre is like really
[ __ ] weird
camp guy said i watched
scanners and blowout this week
looked for escape from new york but they
didn't have it on my streaming service
escape from new york is on
shutter you've never seen escape from
new york right now he's never seen
escape from new york yeah
well i mean wait have you or you just
wanted to watch it again yeah
but yeah i'm pretty sure well shutter
just added a [ __ ] ton she came from new
york's on it of john carpenter stuff
like they added escape from new york the
fog um prince of darkness
uh what the [ __ ] else did they shouter's
got that yeah yeah like they just like
the other day they added well they tend
to
shudder like they have like people that
like curate you know their thing so
they'll tend to like add like a [ __ ] ton
of one type of like i think the other
day like they added a whole bunch of
stephen king adaptations you know like
misery and cat's eye and stuff like that
then they added a bunch of giallo movies
and then one time like a couple months
ago they added a bunch of folk horror
you know what i mean so they'll add like
a bunch of stuff like that like at one
time and i think they just added like a
whole [ __ ] ton of john carpenter stuff
um let's see
one of the funniest i've seen is be kind
rewind with jack black where these guys
work at the vhs rental store i don't
think i ever saw that actually i quite
like jack black he's quite charming
so that sounds like something that he's
got some movies i like to really enjoy i
really like the nacho libre it was a
good one that is very funny yeah well
and he was in that one d
he was in that one too yeah school of
rock was actually pretty funny
um what was the one that he was in where
he put where he was like the funeral
director was it called bernie i don't
know was it called bernie did zoo yeah
you did
you saw it twice matter of fact
i think it was called bernie it was like
where he played he played the guy who
went to uh prison
killed a woman
what did he kill a woman i don't know i
don't remember it was something to do
with like funeral like a funeral home or
something like that
right and it wasn't it was kind of a
comedy but it was like kind of a drama
too it was it was no it was it was based
on a real true crime
oh yeah it may be right he killed the
woman that he was living with
yeah yeah yeah
uh to live in her house or something
i think i don't know life in prison for
it
yeah it was pretty good
hugo says carpenter's body bags is good
i tell everybody to see body bags
because i kind of feel like it's one
that we reviewed it like a long long
time ago
um and it's kind of like a horror
anthology that a lot of people don't
talk about but it's really really good
actually
grampher says granthar's list of weird
movies from his teenage years 1984 with
john hurt yep remember that one elephant
man with john hurt
yeah i see it i see a theme coyana
scotsie yeah i actually i really liked
uh koiana scotty i've seen it a couple
times and faces of death
ours were like i said i think like santa
sangre there was um
uh bartleby that was one that we watched
a bunch
um i kind of want to watch that again
with crisp and glover
uh various john waters movies
various david lynch movies
uh particularly wild at heart i think
that was one that we used to watch a lot
like in high school i can't believe the
camp guy had never seen escape from new
york
he just shrugged that off i asked him if
he'd never seen that he's talking to
other people now
but uh no no if you haven't seen that
you gotta read you gotta rent that one
on amazon
amazon has it i think it's three dollars
yeah i mean most of the movies on there
are just like two or three times or 3.99
but like i said if you had shutter like
i'm pretty sure it's on shutter because
i think they just added a bunch of those
i don't think they added body bags but i
think body bags is free on tubie or it
was last time i looked but yeah that's a
really really underrated uh
horror anthology and you know how much i
love my anthologies i'm actually putting
up a um
review of an old anthology from the
1960s
tomorrow
a vincent price one
called twice told tales
based on the stories of nathaniel
hawthorne
so you know camp guy said we never had
hbo when i was a kid yeah well
the only reason that i had it as a kid
and i probably brought this up before
was my dad worked for cablevision so we
got free cable
so
like i said as soon as mtb started as
soon as like all the pay channels like
he got all that [ __ ] for free if we had
to pay for it we wouldn't so that's why
he didn't that's why he didn't see the
escape from new york yeah
i guess because he didn't have hbo
i don't think i saw well i don't think i
saw it on cable i think i rented it i
think i saw it in the theater
i saw it in the theater i was pretty
well it what was it it came out in 81
right yeah it was r but i think my dad
took me to see it now see i would have
been nine and that probably was not
something that my parents would have
taken me to see
when i was nine
you know what i mean
so i probably saw it later
you can get the deleted scenes
there they come on the uh on the blu-ray
and they probably uploaded them to uh
to youtube
but it shows
shows snakes bank robbery
what standard prison
and i think there might have been some
other stuff that was in there that they
cut out it's pretty good but the best oh
yeah the the bank robbery
shows that uh him and his partners
escape
when they were going down the uh
trans-american railroad
there's like a subway that went across
went underneath the united states and
they were
they were trying to divvy up the [ __ ]
the little credit cards that they stole
they stole a big old thing they were
basically
prepaid atm cards that's what they stole
a whole bunch of them
as you do yeah and uh when they got to
their
location they came out and a bunch of
cops [ __ ] mowed down his buddy and
his arm his army buddy was with him
from the siberian war
i kind of wish they had left that in i
mean i can see why they didn't
but
because maybe they thought well if we
put that like right at the beginning of
the movie then
um then snake pliskin would be less
sympathetic to the audience maybe no
he'd be more pathetic yeah to be honest
like no i'm saying that maybe that's
what they were thinking but i was like
seeing it yeah i was just kind of like
maybe they said why
um
but they eliminated a whole character
out of there that was snake's army buddy
and uh that poor actor i always think
about that every time they cut out a
hole yeah there was a whole kind of like
scenes of like all the actors like man
that poor actor was probably like mom i
got a movie role and she's like you're
not in this [ __ ] what are you talking
about he had an action he had an action
scene and everything
and then uh
they wanted you not to know
how the robbery went down so you could
use your imagination how bad he was
about how bad snake was but really it
was a
it wasn't an armed robbery they used a
bunch of technology to do it and there
was stolen there's they showed a damn
robot like a [ __ ] evil r2d2 looking
thing in the bank it was just like a
it was like a bank that was filled with
atms
that's what it was like it was like an
electronic bank and they had ended up
stealing a whole
uh
duffel bag full of prepaid atm cards
and he was dressed as a bank employee
snake was
so in some way an inside job
crybaby's quoting from wild at heart
yeah i was just thinking about books i
really want to see wild at heart again
because i haven't seen it in such a long
time i was just thinking about crispin
glover was also in that playing jingle
dell i'm making my lunch but yeah so
they're talking about blue velvet
river's edge excalibur yeah those were
also good ones um what was that one
was i remember watching this at my
friend's house we wanted to see it
because the soundtrack was cool i was
particularly excited because it was a
nick cave song on the soundtrack what
was it called until the end of the world
and i remember like watching that movie
going what the [ __ ] is like i don't i
was like i don't know if this is the
most awesome movie ever the most boring
movie ever i can and i still don't know
i'd probably have to like watch it again
john smith said trick-or-treat is my
favorite horror anthology so far
trick-or-treat is
great i mean probably my favorite horror
anthology is still creep show
but
i mean there's lots of good ones i love
anthologies trick or treat is great if
you haven't seen the mortuary collection
that is also great um that's on shutter
i think and that's kind of new i think
it's 2020 or 2021. um that one was
really fantastic i liked that one a lot
too yeah read slash your fred's comment
okay hold on i read that oops in escape
from new york that there was going to be
a plot twist that was going to reveal
the virus injected into snake was a hoax
i kind of thought i thought it wasn't
anyway i mean yeah in a way i'm kind of
glad they just left it like they didn't
explain it either way like because it
didn't really matter in the end but i
didn't because look at it this way how
long would it have taken for them to get
get something like that ready
yeah
well much easier to just be like hey
saline solution and be like yeah this is
going to make your head blow up
or whatever it makes more sense if they
just would have tricked him
yeah like i said much cheaper yeah
uh but
when i first saw the movie after several
times of watching it
i was like i bet you there's no i bet
you there's no capsules in there yeah i
mean i always kind of thought that that
was probably the case i mean they just
wanted him to do what they wanted to do
to come back then just come back you
know what i mean
uh danny rowling has anyone seen the
horror film the boy too and if so is it
worth watching
um
did we see that in the theater i kind of
feel like maybe we did
and i you know what i didn't actually
even mind the first the boy
but
i saw the boy too and then i was just
like so we're just [ __ ] on
everything that happened in the first
one now is that what's going on um like
not that i was super invested in
it or anything
there was no virus in escape from new
york it was explosive it was yeah i
think that's what they neutralized the
virus was in escape from
l.a and i think they injected him with a
virus and that he got hot he was getting
hot
and i think it was a hoax
oh he's getting hot already remember
that he was having a break i have a
favor i haven't seen an escape from yeah
i got to see that one again i have it
but i rarely watch it i don't like it
that much
i think it escaped from la they they
told him that they injected him with a
virus that would kill him in a certain
amount of time if he wasn't back
and he was starting to run a fever
towards the end but then once he got it
over with this without her to worry
about it it was it was harmless it's
just a harmless flu we gave you
it was just just uh just to give you
motivation something if i remember
correctly
john smith said speaking of an actor cut
out of a film rick mayo was cut out of
the first harry potter movie in which he
played a ghost i remember hearing about
that poor rick male he's a r.i.p he
passed away like several years ago but
man i love brickmail he was on the the
young ones
and uh i
i remember hearing that he was in the
first harry potter movie but
um weird movies from grantham's
adulthood spring breakers that's the
harmony korean one right uh lola
american honey and the witch man i love
the witch
that was so [ __ ] good
you know what i i just put up this is
what i meant to say like a long time ago
and then we got like distracted
when we were talking about movies and i
just put up a review
yesterday of the darren aronofsky movie
mother
and
one of y'all commented
you were talking because i thought it
was like brilliant i thought it was like
a masterpiece but i said well i could
see like this one got a lot of hate uh
which i can see that but i loved it i
thought it was great
and one of y'all commented that it's
like yeah i thought this was a
masterpiece too or whatever it's like i
bet tom would hate this movie and then i
was thinking about it i was like i don't
know if you would though you might have
really dug it because you really liked
noah yeah
and this one
it's not the same as noah but
it's along the same lines in the sense
that it's like a biblical allegory even
though it's like set in the modern day
kind of
so i don't know you might really it's
one of those ones that i can't really
tell like either you either you would
think it was amazing or you would think
it was the stupidest thing ever hugo
asked me if i liked escape from la
um yes and no
there were a lot of there's a lot of
stuff about escape from la i liked
but the tone was wrong
it was almost like a parody movie
and um
you know looking crustal had a lot to do
with that movie i think i think he might
have produced it but he he wanted to
bring it back but i thought it was a
little cappy
um it looked they had more of a budget
so they thought that more was better
now no
less is more
it had been better if they did it old
school style
where you just have to find some
destroyed
real location to film this thing
and just make it real low down and and
dirty you know kind of like the kind of
the first one that's why it was so
convincing because they were real
locations you know and they had real
good miniatures you know with the
world trade center and the the glider
and man all that [ __ ] was good
in escape from la man i liked the
submarine i thought that was great the
cg wasn't great i i think i would have
just used practical effects that's kind
of the first thing i always think of
when i think of that is like the surfing
the surf and how fake it looks like the
green screen and everything yeah and
then they try to
um
they made la
look way too populated and
uh it looks too advanced
there's just problems with it you know
um another thing that i didn't like is
that
they gave snake in the second one
another cool weapon they gave him the
core burner
which was a it was like an it was like a
xm177 or an m4 carbine but it was just
like tricked up
to look cool and
he had it for about five minutes and
lost it
so he's supposed to be this badass
special force assault he loses his
weapon that quickly
it's just
and then he's reliant on revolvers
there were just certain things that you
know i think in the script
just the the script kind of
it wasn't that good you know it wasn't
as good as the first one
but man there was a lot of potential
there
you know i just well the thing about
escape from new york is that the reason
it worked was because one it was a great
premise but
that is inherently really a premise
that's only going to work well one time
yeah if you try to like do a sequel and
it's like oh this improbable [ __ ] like
happened again again no one's gonna buy
that like in a completely different part
of the country i would now there's
another movie that was kind of supposed
to be
a snake pliskin movie like a part three
it's called lockout
and it was like escape from space
and it had the guy from who played who
who was in prometheus the guy who played
whalen what was that guy's name uh
um what's that actor's name that played
weyland from well i'm trying to think of
it just uh he's kind of a skinny guy
yeah i know um anyway it doesn't matter
but he he basically plays like a
different version of snake plisk and he
goes up into orbit
and rescues some hostage and brings her
down it was it was an orbital prison i
have it's pretty good yeah we watched
that yeah uh lockout is what it's called
and um
guy pierce i think is what the guy's
name is that's right guy pierce well i
knew i was trying to think of it but
yeah i think his name is sometimes if if
it's quiet for a few minutes i'll think
of it
the thing is though is that this three
thing that's three times in a row that
snake would have done that if they were
all sneak plus that's what i'm saying so
it starts to become [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah you're like you're really this [ __ ]
is happening again it's just kind of
well it gets to a thing where i don't
know why i just made this association
but you know the scooby-doo cartoon yeah
and it's like every time like the scooby
gang like go on vacation somewhere it's
like oh there's somebody pretending to
be a ghost to scare away people
it's like how many times is this going
to happen to you [ __ ] it's like
you don't even it's not even like they
get called up that would be more likely
if they got called up like the
ghostbusters hey come investigate this
[ __ ] no it's just wherever they go there
happens to be like some [ __ ] like that
going on and i'm just like
that's just not how [ __ ] works at real
life i would have done
if i was
with john carpenter
first of all it got him trump
and get him high
until
because the thing escaped from new york
to me tonally they're very similar those
two movies i can watch those two movies
back to back and i'm happy it's like
another world you know that's the
carpenter verse okay
and uh
i'd say don't do escape from new york
again you gotta put snake on a different
kind of mission totally different
out in the wilderness or something
somewhere
so what i'm actually talking about is
like you know you know that you know the
you know the video games [ __ ] um
metal gear like something snake from
metal gear would do
where he has to do something kind of
impossible but it's not in a prison it's
some military facility or some almost
like a james bond mission i do i'd have
him do something like that yeah cause
you can have the same character but you
just don't have him be like oh you have
to go into this
prison area and bring somebody back it's
like yeah because that seems to be too
unlikely yeah that's what i'm saying
it's more likely that on the back of
that that they might contact him again
and offer him a bunch of money to do
something that's interesting
because they'd get in trouble if they
got caught doing it and it's a it's a do
or die one-of-a-kind mission and you got
to do this and nobody's got to know that
it was us that hired you you know you
get caught it's you're on your own that
kind of [ __ ] and then yeah they [ __ ]
put some poison capsules in him or
something to up the stakes he's like i
didn't agree to this well we're gonna
give you a million dollar bonus you know
that kind of [ __ ]
well okay yeah yeah that's supposed to
have done something like that
which would have been like something out
of out of like one of the metal gear
video games
which i played i have one of those
uh two of them metal gear
uh
metal gear
one of the newer ones i don't remember
which one
there were two of them they're pretty
good
they're all right dave kennington says
clue was one of my favorite films
growing up me too and actually i've been
wanting to rewatch that one i love that
[ __ ] movie uh great cast produced by
deborah hill uh yeah that's right john
carpenter's misses for a while and
written and directed by the guy who
wrote yes minister it is a classic yeah
and [ __ ] tim curry we always like to
see tim curry um flames on the side of
my face but uh yeah gramster says the
wrestler was a modern classic i agree i
think i saw that in the theater actually
that was also darren aronofsky you would
probably really like the wrestler i'm
not i'm on the fence over whether
whether you'd like mother or not because
i watched it
and i thought it was brilliant and then
i was kind of like i wonder if tom would
like this i said but he liked noah yeah
and this is even though it's not like
noah it's kind of like noah does that
make any sense like it's like i said
it's a biblical allegory
and um
you know so i so maybe you'd like it i
don't know i i want to watch it again
one day
uh john smith said noah was the most
terrifying movie i've ever seen but i
was coming down from an lsd trip at the
time yeah that'll do it
that'll do it yeah you should probably
see the see the wrestler though that was
also darren aronofsky and that had um
mickey rourke in it
uh and it was great and you've still
never seen rec room for a dream have you
yeah you should probably see that one
too jennifer connolly's in that
johnson's head
how did a british guy become the [ __ ]
american president in this game they
just grabbed donald pleasant and made
him the president and honestly
i love that role it's donald pleasance
i'll allow it
he says they're not humiliating me
enough so they put the [ __ ] wig on
him and [ __ ] [ __ ] he said he was
hamming it up
donald pleasant's always seemed like a
fun dude yeah you know what i mean he
didn't have to do that much he just sat
around getting to make money
i mean that was that was not a uh that
was not a demanding role for him yeah
hugo you could act yeah yeah jenny did
you like hagazusa i did i didn't love it
but i liked it yeah i saw it a while
back i think we talked about it or maybe
i talked about i can't remember they're
talking about their favorite comedies
ferris bueller's day off that's a good
one biloxi blues yeah that's pretty good
yeah i haven't seen that one a long time
um let's see
guamacon says i was watching a real
early like before episode 50 episode of
the of our show and i found myself
missing the phrase the crustal sphere
yeah
we haven't seen much of anything from
the crustal sphere like the last crustal
sphere movies we've seen were the
christmas chronicles movies
you know yeah was that the last new
things that we've seen him in
christmas movies yeah yeah the christmas
ones like christmas chronicles which we
still watch every year at christmas the
second one the second one wasn't quite
as good it wasn't quite as good it was
still worth watching didn't do for a
third one i wonder if you know it
wouldn't surprise me if they made a
third one i mean the two of them they're
worth watching you know the second one
i mean the first one's like super fun i
really liked it and like i said we
watched that one like every christmas
yeah um i think we were meeting to watch
both of them last christmas but i don't
think we did we re-watched the second
one
i don't think we did you watch the uh
the two christmas chronicles movies with
crustal and then you listen to [ __ ]
billy idol's [ __ ] happy holidays
album
and then i watch the christmas mystery
science theater episodes which are santa
claus santa claus conquers the martians
and the christmas that almost wasn't
yeah those are the and there's also they
they do like rifftrax does like a bunch
of christmas shorts and stuff too so i
usually watch those as well to put
myself in the mood
the one i saw a rifftrax if you if any
of you guys are like um mystery science
theater fans like or dorks about it like
i am
um rifftrax has a channel and they'll
put up free [ __ ] like sometimes
the weird ass short the shorts are my
favorite to be honest because i don't
know where the [ __ ] they come up with
some of these
weird shorts that they find the short
that they put up yesterday it was like
half an hour long
and it was about
i guess it was meant
for i don't know if it was meant for the
public or if it was meant for law
enforcement and they were talking about
i guess it was made in the 50s
and they're talking about
bunko
which is a very very
archaic term by today's standards
which i guess is
that's like people that like rip off
other people like financially it's like
when they go to some old lady and it's
like hey look i found this big bag of
money um and i'll split it with you but
you have to go to the bank with me and
like give me
however much money like as a good faith
gesture so i know that we're getting you
know it's like these really convoluted
kind of uh scams yeah you know what i
mean and like you know or salesmen that
come to your house and like try to like
get you to like part with your money and
stuff so they used to call that i don't
know where the term originally came from
but they used to call it bunko
and so
this short was called what was it called
bunko
busters or no that wasn't it it was
something it was bunker something and it
was just kind of telling you like how to
avoid these various scams and it was
just kind of like super funny because
they were always kind of like showing
these
clueless old ladies oh of course the
young man i'll go to the bank with you
and take ten thousand dollars out and
like [ __ ] jesus christ i'm like i
don't mean to blame the victim but come
on anytime somebody's telling you hey
let's go to the bank and take ten
thousand dollars out of your account the
answer to that question is always no no
we're not doing that just that's a pro
tip
um let's see joseph said escape from new
york did lead to the myth that air force
one has an escape pod it seems it
doesn't
let's see where i got behind of all the
all the stuff i liked lockout yeah i
remember it being pretty good yeah
lockout was fun yeah
big trouble in little china somebody
brings up that is also super fun i got a
huge deluxe version of that
yeah i think i bought you that yeah
yeah it came with like with the big
case like the big book and stuff like
big truck on it yeah
uh danny rowling said speaking of
scooby-doo i could totally see rob
zombie doing an adult live action horror
version of scooby-doo
don't encourage him don't encourage him
he probably will didn't they make a
live-action scooby-doo didn't they make
several live-action scooby-doos yeah
some of them were porn
no i'm not talking about the porn
version well i mean
yeah but the thing about it is that
anytime you say hey didn't they make a
movie about blah wasn't that wasn't that
a porn movie yes it was always there's
always a foreign version of everything
but i'm just saying not not a foreign
version it was just like a regular
i kind of feel like wasn't matthew
lillard from scream and that [ __ ] was it
wasn't he shaggy
am i crazy there i'm sure there was like
a hole over there
well i didn't either clearly because i
don't remember but i just kind of
vaguely remember like seeing a trailer
and sometimes i think
now the yeah i didn't see it but i
remember seeing trailers for it i think
john goodman was in it like he was fred
my understanding rick moranis was in it
he was barney
that was 90s and my understanding is
that all that [ __ ] sucked that it was
all terrible so i it was well i mean it
sounded terrible yeah i mean
the second that somebody like think of
all the worthwhile movies that because
sometimes i think this too because you
know i l i read a lot of horror books
and stuff like that and i was thinking
to myself man this make a great movie
and then
i see like sometimes like movies that
was like let's make a movie that's like
a live action there's you know not now
but back in the 90s let's make a
live-action flintstones movie i mean the
the second somebody came in your office
and said that get out yeah just get out
i mean what a stupid idea
i think rosie o'donnell was in that [ __ ]
bombed
i don't know if it did or not which
which is alarmed
i mean i just remember seeing the
trailer and then i just forgot about it
like i said
that's because uh [ __ ] they made that
live action popeye movie and i think it
did pretty good
shelley duvall and [ __ ] robin
i think that did pretty well but
and i don't really remember a lot i
think i saw that movie like on cable
yeah i've never seen it on cable but i
don't remember liking it or disliking it
like that's a trip i don't really have
like thoughts about it one way the other
because i don't really like remember cam
guy said a fish called wanda was a great
comedy movie i agree yeah i really like
that one i've seen that one like a bunch
of times
escape from nebraska the search for
something to do
not gonna lie i'd probably watch that
um let's see uh
yeah kayla huggins said it's like the
jurassic park series there wouldn't be a
franchise if the park was safe and
successful or if the characters didn't
keep making the same mistakes
yeah i mean that's kind of the thing but
that said escape from new york if you
must
make a sequel keep the character
but don't make the next mission exactly
like the first mission you know what i'm
saying that's all i'm saying you just
got to change it up enough to make it
like believable because you talk about
escape from new york oh yeah and escape
from la slasher had never been an escape
from la not really no that was a bad
idea
i don't know i don't know what they were
thinking the tone was totally wrong
the tone had to be like the first one
and the firs the tone on the first one
was similar to the thing
you know it was kind of a serious
yeah i mean it had humor but it wasn't
like funny yeah no it wasn't funny and
um
it kind of had a great what was weird
about what was weird about escape from
new york is that when you analyze it
it wasn't an action movie
no it wasn't the action movie it made
you it fooled you into thinking that it
was an action movie but there's very
little action in it
there's a car chase a car crash
and some guns shooting
some shootouts and that's about it
more like an adventure
yeah i think that's the category i think
action adventure i think it usually gets
classed in with action
or action horror or action thriller or
something something like that but sci-fi
dystopian action thriller kind of action
something
i mean it
it had problems the first one
but it was still overall good you know
crossover [ __ ] he was said he was
working out hard to try to [ __ ] gain
some mass he was skinny
he was skinny he was too skinny
but you know it still still came across
i mean he's just he's just doing clint
eastwood and clint eastwood was a skinny
[ __ ] people don't realize it
that dude didn't weigh anything
you know well and he probably weighs
even less nowadays because he looks like
a mummy he looks like a mommy yeah
because he's like 150 years old he was
just a tall skinny dude probably weighed
150 pounds
speaking of clint eastwood we really
still should do play misty for me
because i think he probably liked that
movie
crybaby said black swan was good yeah i
actually really like black spawn i have
honestly i've liked all of darren
aronofsky's movies that i've seen i know
that he's kind of one of those
filmmakers that people are just kind of
like
you know but
i don't know i liked everything and i
don't think i've seen all his movies but
i've seen most of them
i saw pie i saw a requiem for a dream i
saw black swan i saw the wrestler
and then grandparents points out the
wrestler was also a biblical allegory
about job from the old testament oh yeah
i guess so that's kind of darren
aronofsky's thing i guess
although i don't really see requiem for
a dream being a biblical allegory i'll
get although i guess it could be where
where does this stuff man where does the
where does the double-headed dildo come
in
into the bible
i don't
i don't know what you're the end the
infamous scene and requiem perjury i
didn't see it so i don't have anything
where where jennifer connolly and the
other prostitute are like having like
the double-headed dildo with the in
their butts and stuff yeah yeah i don't
know what you're talking about
i can see it and the whole thing with
the like i said ellen burst into this i
know it just happened they showed it
yeah
yeah
it's like it's basically like an
anti-drug movie is what it is and it's
just kind of like
because the ellen burstin is in it like
from the exorcist you know
and
she's on
well some kind of prescription pills or
something like that she starts [ __ ]
losing her marbles like so she thinks
her like refrigerator is coming together
and [ __ ] like that it's crazy it's a
crazy movie yeah not for me no you would
probably like it i know what it sounds
like like when i say that but yeah i
mean it's depressing as [ __ ] i will tell
you that right now but
uh but actually i really liked it
i really liked it even though it is
depressing as [ __ ]
uh speaking of the crustal has tom seen
dark blue yeah i own it yeah excellent
copy copyrighted by james elroy yeah did
we wait did we watched it right yeah
yeah i thought we did he's a bad cop
yeah you don't realize his bad cop
towards the end until you have these
back up oh well there was a spoiler
alert
it was a pretty good one it wasn't my
favorite from him but you know he was
pretty good i liked it
let's see donald pleasance and
christopher lee in 1972's deathline
aka raw meat we actually did a review of
that a long time ago
i think it was like a double feature it
was deathline and something else but i
can't remember what the other movie was
that we talked about but i know we
talked about that one
um
favorite archaic short movie
i started watching one
last night i didn't finish watching it
but it was another rifftrax one and it
actually wasn't a short but it was like
a full-length movie i don't know when
the [ __ ] this movie was from
it was like i'm thinking it was like
early 50s like judging by the way
everyone was dressed and stuff but i
guess
there was a series of movies
starring these characters i guess it was
three of them i didn't see the first one
so i don't really know but it was like
they were called the teenagers
you know that's real specific and i
guess all did it all the different
movies they would get in like different
adventures and these [ __ ] were like
[ __ ] insufferable man and like the
one that i was watching last night they
were going to like this ranch with one
of their teachers and like it was like
cowboy days but it was still supposed to
be modern day so i didn't really get
that but it's just kind of like then one
of them gets mistaken for some
cowboy like some guy that had killed
some sheriff or something like that it
was like the most ridiculous thing ever
i gotta like start to
finish watching german is laying down
some facts for us
i was wrong about the flintstones
said flintstones made a [ __ ] ton of
money see that's what i thought that's
what i suspected but he said that that's
why they kept horrible reviews that's
why they kept [ __ ] making them yeah
it got horrible reviews though he said
well yeah i remember everybody just
saying it sucked
that is but see maybe you just remember
a movie critic saying this sucked which
i'm sure it probably did suck i don't
know i haven't seen it but
just i i can just tell i just thought it
bombed in terms of i figured it sucked
and it didn't make see i thought that it
i had a suspicion i was like i know it
probably got shitty reviews but i was
like i bet it probably made a bunch of
money because they can't do it because
they kept doing it they kept making them
i just saw the trailer i remember seeing
the trailer on tv going oh no
no
because didn't they do something
hey wait did they ever do a live-action
jetsons no
that seemed like the natural next thing
they did if they did i don't remember
there was a lot of stupid [ __ ] that they
did how about a live action
grape ape let's see that
[Laughter]
or what was the one with the big huge
shark
and the and the kids that drove around
solving crimes what the [ __ ] was the
name of that machine no that was that
burp rentals
what was that cartoon was it hannah
barbera
probably am i high yeah you're high
i mean i'm not right now but i'm just
saying there was a cartoon yeah there's
a cartoon but i don't remember the name
of it and it had and it was like a giant
shark and he walked around on land he
didn't swim yeah he was the land shark
the [ __ ] wasn't he was electric it's
like sharky something or other
no he wasn't sharky i thought his name
was sharky no what the [ __ ] was it i'll
probably think of it like he had all
hannah barbara was a cheap company they
made a [ __ ] ton of stuff and everything
and they made lots of it they made ones
about [ __ ] world war one looking
airplanes that were
racing planes i think yeah i remember
that they made uh one was that wacky
races i don't know then they made
another one it's about a cars versus
motorcycles racing and the the cars
talked instead of the motorcycle
yeah i remember that one they had just
stupid drugs are a hell of a drug yeah
like drugs
that's what all those all those people
that did all those drugs in the 60s and
70s they started like writing cartoons
right around that time the only
hanna-barbera cartoon that i remembered
liking as the kids as a kid was the
herculoids
oh yeah yeah yeah they were
wait was that the one with the with the
with the dinosaur thing and just yeah
was that the one the shmu they had two
schmooze and two schmidt and they had a
triceratops that was it that's what i
was thinking it's a triceratops and he
could like shoot [ __ ] out of his like
and then they had a big old gorilla that
was like a rock made out of that yeah
yeah yeah he could smash his face
together i didn't remember that he had a
damn dragon that shot lightning out of
its eye out of its tail and laser beams
out of its eyes and it was about a
a a
scientist from earth his wife and his
two kids get stranded on this [ __ ]
ancient planet barbaric planet and then
they kind of i think they adopted as
their home weren't they from weren't
they from earth
you're asking the wrong person all i
remember i don't remember the human
characters i don't give a [ __ ] about
that i just remembered like all the
monsters because they thought they might
have been from earth and that they kind
of
got marooned there but maybe it
might be wrong it was a long time ago i
think johnny quest might have been
hannah barbera though too
i don't think it was i don't think
it was johnny quest was a lot better i
don't think that was hannah barbera yeah
i mean i could be i could totally be
johnny quest is i remember johnny quest
being like when i was a little kid that
was like watching an adult movie it was
yeah it was like wow i was getting that
bandit and hodgy and [ __ ] race
banning race bait yeah and then they had
race bandits [ __ ] scientist buddy
with the red hair and a beard and i go
man it's gi joe because i had a gi joe
look just like that
every time i see jeremy wade's fishing
show i'm just like look it's grace
bannon
he looks just like grace bannon
that's why i started calling him what
okay so
on the herculoids
what were the schmooze powers
like what could this they could they
could
turn into any object you might need
okay
well that's handy
if you were falling they could run
underneath you and turn into a big
trampoline and catch it
you could stretch out and grab things
and i forgot what they were called it
was
it was gleep and gloop or
i think it was called bleep and glue i
think
i think you might be right
there i think there might have been
monkey's name gleeping gleep and gloop
wait where did where did the wonder twin
powers come into this that was [ __ ]
wonder twin powers activate
yeah that was a different cartoon i
think
they all kind of like they all like
mixed together like that
that's what the name that was oh i
remember that song
well actually do you guys remember like
back in the 90s
there was an alternative rock
uh
like album that came out and it was all
like all rock bands like covering
cartoon themes
and i think the reverend horton heat did
a version of stop that pigeon yeah which
was actually quite rad
um
i just remember doing i think was it
helmet or pavement or somebody like that
did gigantor
um
[ __ ] what else i used to have it violent
femmes was on there they were doing that
song from i guess it was like the
flintstones eb bork
yeah they did that one
and uh it was a good album actually i
was talking about g-force
yeah g-force
g-force had a [ __ ] the bad guy was a
rip-off of [ __ ] batman i think it was
just he was had batman's outfit and
everything if i remember correctly
what was funny is that
there were several
cartoons that were shown here in the
united states that were actually just
cut up
japanese series re-engineered for an
american audience and the stories didn't
had no
resemblance to the originals and g-force
was one of them
the japanese version was a lot better
and we never got it this is just like
star blazers i think was the name of one
of the other ones star it was in
i think it was star blazers
no there was a star blazers but that's
not the one i'm thinking of
they took
a japanese uh
they took grendizer grand eyes or ufo
and [ __ ] re-engineered that into some
piece of [ __ ]
and then they took they did the same
thing i think with uh
getter robo g
and those were real good
um go nagai
that was the name of the japanese guy
that made him it was like their version
of stan lee those were go nagai
animes turned in or anime comics that
were turned into uh
uh there's even
no that's they don't call that anime
what do they call it mangas yeah they
were mangas that were turned into anime
for japan
i have them i i have the originals
but there are copies
because there's not license for the
united states
but i was watching him as a little kid
on uhf22
or was that vhf20 it was vhf 22 in
california on the japanese channel
because we had japanese people living in
california at that time
back in the 70s so i saw them but i
couldn't understand them
but i got i loved them as kids i started
[ __ ] collecting the toys and they
they got here as the shogun warriors
which are knockoffs really of the
originals the original toys were even
better back in japan
but
the reason why they changed them up for
the united states
is that the originals had themes that
would never be accepted in the united
states the women had nipples
on their uniforms that's one thing that
they didn't like
um
people got killed in the comics in in
the mangas they weren't for kids they
were more for teenagers
in japan
the bad guys were demons from the center
of the earth in one series and they
would [ __ ] demonically possess people
and animals
and they would die and blow up and [ __ ]
they're like oh we can't show this to
kids and we can't have any references to
the [ __ ] pandemonium army with
[ __ ]
evil demons in the center of the earth
and one of the demons was named a
general histor and it's definitely ed
adolf hitler with horns so they didn't
want they had to kind of edit him out
and general bry was this but the
originals were so much better than the
than the [ __ ] we got
it was the same with grendizer
well g-force was one like that
i don't remember the original name of
geforce but i do remember that one
and
it was pretty good even the american
version it was pretty good but they say
the original japanese version was about
a thousand times better
because they were more for adults or not
really adults but more for teenagers
and they were long they ran for a long
time
they were like mini series like
the jet the japanese were doing on
television what we only started doing in
netflix with like [ __ ] the walking
dead and [ __ ]
really good series the japanese did that
[ __ ] forever
well the thing about well they did that
not just with cartoons but they did that
with movies
live action too because
on i mean some of the some of the um
stuff that they did on mystery science
theater like um i'm trying to think of
like some of the ones that they did but
some of the movies that they did on
their movies
were there was this production company
owned by this person named sandy frank
and he would buy
series from japan and then recut them to
like movie length and they were
completely incomprehensible
because he was cutting down like
8 10 12 hours yeah of a show yeah and
stuffing it into like an hour and a half
and it made absolutely no sense yeah
well that's what that's what the america
that's what the con that's what g-force
was and stuff like this and and star
blazers and [ __ ] like that they cut it
all down
um [ __ ] it up they were also doing a
live action stuff yes saban
bought
basically go ranger and [ __ ]
tricked that up and released it as power
rangers
and the the model was so successful that
the japanese
had like exclusive agreements with
[ __ ] saban
who was just a producer here you know
for merchandising and
they made in japan they actually shot
their series so it was easy to
cannibalize and turn into an american
series so we could so they can insert
american actors in an american story
based on their
costumes and
and and special effects
action scenes that were filmed in japan
but the japanese original japanese
series of all that [ __ ] was was
superior to what we got
it was called sentai and super sentai
when i was a little kid i was seeing the
real thing
in california on channel 22 which is a
vhf channel
and the one i saw was go ranger was one
of them and that was the original power
rangers it was bad ass
people were getting blown up
evil women with [ __ ] eyes where the
titties would be and [ __ ]
tentacles coming out of the top percy
crazy [ __ ] man and [ __ ] they would never
show in the united states
and uh everybody would blow up and
people throwing grenades and bombs at
each other and machine guns and
ramping over machine guns yeah
motorcycles and [ __ ] and then they had
another one i didn't know what it was at
the time but then i found out later
it was kamen rider
you can google all this [ __ ] what it
looked like kamen rider was weird too
it was kind of like power rangers
mixed with batman and had a dude look
like a damn insect or something he
looked like an insect com
like a motorcycle helmet with two big
old eyes on it and
green house why don't they make more
more motorcycle helmets that look like
big like praying matches yeah that's
what it looked like i look like a
praying mantis head does anybody have
something like that that seems like
something that should be available
france is into [ __ ] like that
but it looks more like that's cool i
would i would have i would have that
kind of thing yeah
get like a green jacket
looking like a [ __ ] bug
that was a good one
i'm trying to remember the um
[Music]
the one series well there was more than
one but there was one series that they
did a couple of them on mystery science
theater
and the movies like i said were just
the best one and it's like i said i'll
probably remember it like 10 minutes
from now but
they're
what the [ __ ] was the name of that thing
i don't remember but so the guy comes to
like this other planet like for whatever
reason like all the bad guys
and i saw this a lot in japanese movies
i don't know if this is like a thing for
japanese movies like from the 50s and
60s and stuff but it's like the bad guys
were wearing makeup and sometimes like
blonde wigs yeah yeah yeah
like i was like looking like okay
i mean you do you like whatever but i
thought i'm missing some cultural
context there i think rebecca says in
australia car the cartoons we saw 99 of
the time were dc hannah barbera looney
tunes and the flintstones only marvel we
ever saw was spider-man that's pretty
much what we got too i mean
honestly
most of my childhood was looney tunes
and hanna-barbera cartoons with some
other things german says penelope
pitstop and hong kong phooey yeah
remember we're big kids tv 1970s yeah i
don't remember penelope pit stop but i
do remember hong kong movie first pissed
off was a cute little blonde racer girl
who had like a little carmen gear race
car
and i didn't she had something to do
with tom slick wasn't she part of this
tom slick series i don't remember it was
it was just kind of like a 60s racing i
mean it sounds familiar but it didn't
make much kind of like a female
female um
speed racer
but it was a lot funnier speed racer was
actually uh kind of serious for for for
the time
the speed racer series was pretty close
that the united states got was
close to the original a lot closer to
the original than with some of the other
stuff
that we got was all
chopped up another one that we got that
was pretty that was close to the
original was to tsujin 28.
we knew it we knew it as a as gigantor
if i remember correctly about a robot
and then dude he could run it on remote
control and get him with gigantor and
[ __ ]
cartoon yeah
yeah yeah gigantor tsujin 28 was the was
the original name for it though
it's kind of like giant robot
with johnny sacco that was a that was a
live action incentive it's pretty good
dave kennington said funniest film ever
double down or any neil breen film oh my
god i honestly have never sat through an
entire neil breen film but
i've seen pieces of most of them
because
our boy over at
on the shitcase cinema channel
uh
reviews a lot of his movies and like
shows clips of them and they look
hilarious but i'd really have to be like
in the and like not for the reasons you
might think but um yeah so one of these
days i'll probably have to
have like get really drunk and like
watch some of the [ __ ] because
i don't know man i don't know there
but the guy okay so neil breen is like
one of those guys
that
he's like well you know i can make
movies and i'm going to be in all my
movies and in all of his movies he's
always
like
he always casts himself as like the hero
but not just the hero he's always kind
of like i'm an angel that's come to
earth to like save her but i mean you
know it's obviously like a really like
ego stroking kind of project which makes
it like even funnier
so
it's that it's not funny for the same
kind of reasons as the dude that made
like burdemic and replicas and like
those kind of movies that guy
just he seems like a nice man and
everything but that guy i can't remember
what his name is right now but um
that guy it's almost kind of like he's
from another planet and doesn't really
know like humans work
which is what makes his movies funny
which is kind of the same reason why
like the room is funny um but
neil breen's movies are funny it's
because the movies are they're not
competently made or anything like that
but you can tell that like the guy that
made them is like a total egomaniac yeah
and
that is like how about that dude neil
brainia and that's just like funny in
itself because it's like it's very clear
that he's like i'm gonna cast myself as
like the savior of mankind yeah and i'm
just going to float down to earth and
i'm an angel and i'm just like i'm
healing you i'm just like oh my god
seriously dude
it's so [ __ ] hires these
girls young enough to be his daughter
who are far outside of his
natural abilities and he's there to
impress them through the whole movie i
mean definitely his ego trip fantasy
yeah definitely which like i said hey
a superior alien yeah an angel
or something kind of in between the two
like that has he been a ninja yet oh i
don't know no he's always some kind of a
he's always some kind of celestial
celestial i feel like that is totally
good and here to save the planet and
free energy and how to solve all these
you're going to solve all of mankind's
problems
like i said look if you want to make
like maybe get laid
well yeah that's again that's very
important that's very important that's
why you're solving mankind's problems
yeah
if he wasn't going to get any trim out
of it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it it's too much work but
if i'm getting some [ __ ] on the side
yeah so it just seems like okay
if you want to like write fanfic or make
movies or something like that where you
were like king of the universe or
whatever fine but it's like don't
inflict it on other people come on
nobody wants to see that although
it would like maybe do inflict it on
other people because it's like super
funny like it's [ __ ] hilarious but
yeah i mean [ __ ] case cinema he doesn't
like i said he doesn't post that often
anymore he's a british dude he's a
writer as well he's a novelist um but
every now and then he does a lot of
steven segal movies too
but he does a lot of nail brain movies
yeah he just like sees he just like
watches like the shittiest of the shitty
so we mentioned in battle of the planets
that was no shoes battle i remember the
name battle of the planets but i can't
quite place it i
it's standing out i like i remember
liking battle of the planets but i can't
quite remember what it was
i liked uh i liked uh the one about
battleship yamato that was a good one i
think that was also known as star
blazers in
rise
the
united
motto to sucking yamato out of the
[ __ ]
ground and turn it into a spaceship and
it goes runs out to get revenge on the
uh avenge the planet earth because it
had been [ __ ] destroyed by these damn
aliens you're trying to track them down
it was damn damn aliens blew the [ __ ] up
yeah as they do as they do sometimes
it's kind of like battlestar galactica
in a way where instead of
they don't they're not searching for the
their home they're searching for the
home planet of the bad guys
in the space in the battleship you motto
is pretty cool then
the battle of the planets
man i know that name
trying to remember which one that was
that was all before robotech came out
that's pre robotech
70s dave kennington talking about neil
breen uh he was a soldier in one i've
been awarded every medal
yeah
which metal did you get all of them all
of them yeah every single one
they're just like all over his uniform
like all over the back and like which
would be universal
i even got arctic surface ribbon
yeah yes six months in the six months in
our antarctica
oh my god yeah that's like that's
[ __ ] hilarious douche
i mean
well i
can't imagine like what would possess
you yeah like i could see like maybe
doing that like for your own amusement
like or just to jack off or whatever but
it's just kind of like why
release that it's like oh people need to
see this i'm like no they really don't
they really releasing it for himself
and it's like and i don't know
like i said like like people like that
he seems like to have no self-awareness
whatsoever and he's just like look
everyone's just gonna like laugh they're
all gonna laugh at you just like
carrie's mom said
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like and i think he maybe doesn't
understand like why people are laughing
i don't know like but everybody on earth
like thinks that's [ __ ] hilarious
come on come on
okay i gotta pee like
you you talk
you talk um
grafton says steven seagal is in russia
these days talking [ __ ] about ukraine
and the u.s and he sensed the links he
sends a link
um yeah well i told i don't i don't know
what he's [ __ ] saying but i told you
how that [ __ ] was gonna go i called it
i don't know if they've [ __ ]
announced it
they had well i know they haven't
announced it to the american public but
[ __ ] ukraine's [ __ ] trashed they
have no chance they they lost that one
russia got all the russian-speaking
areas back
and then which is half the damn country
which is what started the war anyway
we overthrew [ __ ]
america did what it does is overthrowing
[ __ ] duly elected governments
because we don't make money that way
and uh those the russian speakers in
ukraine [ __ ] got pissed and they
[ __ ] helped the russian army and
they're gonna go back to russia that was
always russia anyway
russia came from ukraine that's like
their version of philadelphia
at least the eastern half of it
it was always just disputed territory
borders of [ __ ] ukraine were always
up to whatever [ __ ] empire was around
it at the time
we talked about cigar again yeah segal
talking [ __ ] but i'm just saying you
know that was it's easy to talk [ __ ]
about that you they didn't have a chance
i think seagal has kind of the same
problem as neil
breen does no no well it's just
much worse it's a similar problem yeah
like people that think entirely too much
of themselves and don't like
well we we kind of went on we we kind of
[ __ ] i kind of a couple days we
touched on this and and and
where we drew parallels between glenn
danzig
and steven stevenson
but
there's a big difference between the two
they're on the spectrum but there's a
big difference
and the difference is is that danzig can
[ __ ] deliver okay danzig can [ __ ]
sing yeah i mean at least he has talent
i saw him live
in 95 and that [ __ ] kicked ass
he was [ __ ] great to see live he can
sing
he can write music and do
steven seagal [ __ ] claims to be able
to do everything he's a [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] yeah he is [ __ ] nobody is
good at everything right nobody right
knowing your weaknesses is actually like
a really good thing to
can do a keto but a keto isn't all that
impressive that's the problem okay
keto is not a real martial art no i
wouldn't cons that's mma you can't take
that into an mma event you'd get your
ass kicked you know you have to train
for mma
but aikido is not a
no
we'll see aquino is a bullshitto like i
said he was [ __ ] if he was just good
at that yeah and if he was like in some
movies then that'd be fun and then he
didn't like talk anything out like how
he was awesome at everything and like
you know it then that would be fine and
like didn't take himself all that you
know if he didn't take himself so
seriously like people wouldn't make
jokes about him all the time i think
that was ma
mostly why people like [ __ ] on them all
the time
well because he takes himself way too
seriously michael schaefer said who
would win in a fight seagal or a sheetah
kim
oh chagall well segal would probably
just sit on yeah
[Laughter]
depends on what at what time you're
talking about when it comes to yeah like
now it will wait a kim's dead uh he's
probably not around that dude's probably
probably
he was old then
but he'd be in no shape to fight but in
their primes
[ __ ] cigar would [ __ ] stomp a mud
hole in a sheet of camp well he's much
bigger
yeah even before he got fat the reason
why seagal
was good at aikido is because
or good at kicking people's asses with a
keto is because he was about six foot
something and weighed a lot he he he was
pretty big he had good reach he was
never very muscular
and he knew who he could pick on he'd
pick on a little [ __ ] with a little
[ __ ] actor do we go
yeah john leguizamo john look his head
was like a foot shorter than him yeah
he's like four
yeah
that'd be like steven seagal picking on
me right now
kim and man i'm [ __ ] so pissed that
[ __ ] i was so pissed at youtube when
they took the when they took the [ __ ]
that that channel down
[ __ ] i should have copied that [ __ ]
somehow uh too late now but it's gone
now we'll go over to dailymotion maybe
they moved over to mainly motion or
maybe somebody copied it and put it on
dailymotion i'm sure it's someplace yeah
what was this what was his name the uh
[ __ ] oh i got i go with the name of
it but that dude would sit there and
[ __ ] talk about [ __ ] a sheet of
kim and it was [ __ ] hilarious
hilarious what was the name of that
channel
something another gentleman or something
no the pink man the pink man oh yeah i
remember that guy i think i watched that
when we were like preparing to do the
show about it yeah so it was still there
then it's called the pink man in one
word on youtube but they took the
channel down because he was using clips
from kung fu movies and they said it was
all copyrighted and he was just
he was he was
he was smoking them too hard he was just
[ __ ] people up martial artist
calling him out bulshito
sagal was one of the main ones then the
other one he went off on was [ __ ] a
sheet of kim he went off on did a whole
video she became super fun to pick on
yeah and then and then he went off went
off on what was that dude thinking it
went off on [ __ ] um the dude from
[ __ ] that that was supposedly the guy
from [ __ ]
that steven's that that from one movie
was dead uh death match no
way are you talking about frank ducks
frank ducks did one on frank duck
bloodsport bloodsport it was
epic epic [ __ ] rants and they were
poetic he he wrote him down before he
yet before he you know it was all he
wrote the [ __ ] down like a script and
went through and with his nerdy voice he
sounded like [ __ ] woody allen talking
about [ __ ] martial arts
but no he got him he kept and he knew
you know he knew a lot about martial
arts he was a martial artist himself the
pink man
but i think it was mma
or mixture
because he didn't know martial arts but
i think he was mostly into mma
and would just sit there and just pick
those dudes apart their histories and
what they said at certain times and then
what they claim to have been able to do
and
where this comes from and the pink man
also did a whole one on ninjas
yeah i watched that one too that one was
really good yeah
he uh
basically
goes through the whole thing so there
were no ninjas
not really no i mean not in the way it
turned out in the movies i think we did
we did the show about it yeah we did we
did it i'm pretty sure yeah cause i
think we i watched it like before we did
that dave kennington said not sure
seagal could win a fight against kim
cattrall these days
[Laughter]
he's got masks that's pretty funny
well like i said if he sat on you you'd
be in trouble he could sit on you and
fart in your face he could just get a
hold of you really unpleasant and pull
you towards him and wrap himself around
you and just hug you like that and fall
and you'd have a hard time you know
mass
mass has a certain powers of all its own
you know i mean like
there are some fat big fat dudes
that are not physically fit that you
don't want to [ __ ] with
because if they get a hold of you you
can't get up underneath them especially
if there's a big size and weight
difference between you two i mean it'd
be like a semi-truck tire yeah like yeah
well it's like a big heavy octopus you
know i mean and you just can't get out
you can't get out of it and you can
punch all you want but it's just padding
that's what i mean
that's only like one or two families
there they got like all kind of
protection and people watch too many
[ __ ] these [ __ ] crazy ass movies
with these 120 pound [ __ ] sexy chicks
beating up like five bad ass dudes she's
wearing a [ __ ] miniskirt you know it
doesn't work that way
i mean um
if somebody can pick you up
you have a very hard time beating that
person
all right
uh it's and it's just physics if someone
can pretty much easily pick you up
you're [ __ ]
probably you should just run yeah
and it's because you know and
that's the reason why children don't
beat up adults
okay you tell me when's the last time a
child has beat up an adult it doesn't
happen you can just pick a child up
throw that child you know it's just
i mean don't do that yeah but you can
you know well it's the same thing
hypothetically yeah
[Laughter]
as soon as you're off the ground any all
of your punches the [ __ ] power behind
them kind of evaporated because you're
not pushing off from the ground
to [ __ ] conduct any [ __ ] power
into that person it'd be like trying to
just be floating in the water trying to
punch a guy underneath the pool you
can't really hardly do it you punch him
and you move back you know i mean it's
like that
you just can't connect you know
so no mass has a lot to do with it
you know
it's not all this so maybe that's how
seagal like still justifies yeah talking
about how awesome he is he's like well
if worse comes to worse like i said i
can just fall on grabber
will grapple and it'll be on the ground
and i'll [ __ ] smother you and [ __ ]
yeah it's like fighting and he's like
yeah i haven't even i haven't even like
worn deodorant for like five days you'll
die from like the [ __ ] sting it
depends on how much you weigh and who
you are yeah that wouldn't work with
everybody you know
we're so mean
we're not mean we're just like mean to
like particular people like i said if he
was cool
and had a sense of humor about himself
then like i said nobody would like
nobody would make fun of them there's
mental illness there you just gotta you
just gotta be real i think there's
mental illness there he's a pathological
liar
yeah i mean he's clearly got some pro
and and he lies about things that are
like really really easy yeah or
well the thing about it yeah maybe he
just started back when it was not so
easy to check and then he's like well
[ __ ] now i'm kind of like locked into
this [ __ ] now so it's like i can't
really go back on the stuff or it'll be
like really shameful he was like frank
ducks frank was definitely a
pathological liar
just a passion i've never understood
that at all i've never i mean i know
it's a mental illness of some kind it's
gotta be yeah because i was watching um
that show the unexplained like the
william shatner one
and i was watching an episode on hulu
last night
about
people with double lives it was kind of
like people that are like imposters and
stuff and they were talking about like a
couple they didn't talk about like some
of the better known better known ones i
guess like kind of like frank abagnale
and stuff but
they talked about one guy
who was like a french dude and i guess
he like came to
the u.s and like he lived in hollywood
and he was like kind of
ingratiated himself like with all these
wealthy people and it's like he was
scammed like money out of them so he was
always kind of like going around like
coming up with new names and [ __ ] like
that so they were talking about
how people like that
it must be some kind of like weird
personality type because it does really
seem like some people are just kind of
like even from a young age they're just
kind of like i'm just going to make all
this [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah i'm named this
and i grabbed that name
grew up with the dude who was like grab
this you know who we're talking about he
just if he was talking he was lying
if that mouse was moving he was lying
i've known a couple just couldn't stop
[ __ ] lying and the older maybe they
can't maybe they can't help themselves
it's just yeah it's it's it's no they
can't they can't help themselves it's
just like a kleptomaniac or a serial
killer or anything because it's just
kind of like
it's just [ __ ] that's like that's easy
to like check they just be like uh no
now somebody's
somebody mentioned a good uh example who
was that said that
somebody mentioned butter bean
and that's right
butter bean i think that was that was
might have been deer in ultimate
fighting i don't remember when that was
that ultimate fighting
i forgot what that what kind of fighting
that was that was a long time ago
butterbean was [ __ ] the dude that
appeared in the 90s
i think it was ultimate fighting that
was his name butterbean yeah barbie
that's cool yeah and butter bean like
[ __ ] like
butter bean i'm gonna start calling
pookie that yeah
butter bean was probably like six foot
two or three and was just fat
and just kind of out of shape and when
you look he looked like baby huey he did
just funny looking right was he kind of
oily
no just this [ __ ] white dude did he
just this [ __ ]
and butterbean could [ __ ] you up he was
like a champion because you couldn't
hurt him
and and he wasn't even really
that skilled you know
it was just mass coming at you
and you couldn't hurt him
and
he ended up winning all kinds of [ __ ]
people were rooting for him but if you
look at him you just look like he was
just totally out of shape
totally out of shape that was butterbean
he was a legend he was the shape he was
round
no he's here
he's [ __ ] pear-shaped
he's pear-shaped
butter bean and you go ah i need yell
and [ __ ] i know you're talking about
yeah samantha said uh i only need butter
bean from jackass
okay so he was on jack i didn't know
yeah
camp guy said i hate people like that
like people that lie all the time i
avoid them because there's nothing you
can do or say to get a word in edgewise
yeah it's like people like that it's
like there's really no point like
wasting your time talking to them
because it's like obviously they're just
going to like sit there and
self-aggrandize and like be like and i
just and that and i'm an abc and
i
you know caused world peace and blah
blah and all this other kind of [ __ ] and
just like
who the [ __ ] wants to talk to somebody
like that nobody
yeah michael said butterbean looked like
the king hippo on mike tyson's punch-out
yeah i remember that yeah
i used to have that game
i don't i don't think he was a boxer
though uh if i remember correctly i
think i think butterbean was during the
time of ultimate fighting i think you
guys might be able to correct me
maybe it was boxing
but i think it was like a man i think it
was after boxing like the very very
beginnings of ufc they called it
ultimate fighting
oh that had another name for it too
i mean i kind of remember that but i
don't like now that you're now that
you're saying that it was on jackass i
kind of like vaguely remember that but
because i didn't i saw a little bit of
jackass but not a lot of it but i do
remember king hippo on mike tyson's
punch-out i do remember that game like
me my brother had that
um
was he in the popeye movie
i don't know i don't know
um
tyson is my favorite boxer of all time
honestly i didn't i never really watched
boxing i was you know
i'm not just not really into sports in
general you know
i don't know i don't know
wasn't that was an old movie though like
how long ago are we talking about
when did the the popeye movie when did
that come out 87
87 something like that
i'm amazed that i don't remember i would
you'd think that i would remember
somebody named butterbean for christ's
sake i mean that's a pretty awesome name
but i don't like i don't remember that
at all
i don't remember that at all
um let me see what else
what time is it oh okay it's quarter to
eight we're fine
1980. seriously was that old
holy crap i was thinking it was like
mid-80s i was thinking like 86-87
i didn't realize it was that that was
like the same [ __ ] year as the
shining came out like shelley duvall
being in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
was it really that old
[ __ ]
getting old to [ __ ] man like the 80s
just are all like a big blur but usually
like i'm pretty good at remembering like
the years that movies came out like if
it was the 1980s or 1990s but i didn't
remember the popeye movie being that old
i thought it was 86 or 87 no it was
around the time e.t i think came out
wasn't it mr 88 says 1980 1980 is that
old i was like [ __ ] man that was like
shelly duvall was in that that was the
same year she was in the [ __ ] shining
yeah
yeah okay [ __ ] 1980 i was only [ __ ]
eight years old
so you know it was a long time ago
yeah i don't i don't remember butterbean
like i said you think i'd remember
somebody with a name as frat as that but
i don't
i don't remember
i'm only in my first drink still
yeah well i'm going to try to keep it
look why didn't get let me have one more
yeah i mean we still got a while before
we leave we don't have to leave for a
while
it's only quarter to eight and we don't
actually have to leave till 9 30.
so
we'll be all right
and that was mostly watery anyway
because all the ice melted into it
all the ice melted into it
hey oracle's here hey how you doing
robin williams was on a roll after more
committee honestly i haven't seen it a
long time so it's probably like cringe
worthy to watch now but i used to really
like more community
it's probably
if i watched it now i'd probably be
insufferable because i do kind of feel
like robin williams
he was great in
dramatic roles like later on like he was
great in like i love dead poets society
and one hour photo and he was in good
insomnia and stuff like that
a lot of his comedic role like while i
liked them at the time sometimes if i
watch them now i'm like holy [ __ ] that
dude was so coked up oh my god
dan michael said um shelley duvall was
very pretty even though i usually get
outvoted on that
i always thought she was kind of pretty
too like she but see the thing about it
is that um
[Music]
i always thought shelley duvall was like
she she's interesting looking and i
really like there's something very
attractive about women that are
interestingly and men that are
interesting looking
i kind of feel like and i don't know
maybe i might have brought this up
before but like sometimes when you see
kind of like
even nowadays like you know leading men
leading ladies like big kind of like big
stars or stuff like that a lot of them
just look they're good looking but they
look very generic and a lot of times
they kind of just like look alike to me
they like i can't really tell one from
the other so i'm kind of more interested
in like interesting looking people
and to me like like people that are
interesting looking are like more
attractive than like generically
attractive people if that makes any
sense so i always thought shelly duvall
was really interesting looking she has
like a really interesting face
you know what i mean so i see what
you're saying i get what you're saying
and honestly i mean
i know that when the shining came out
the you know kubrick's movie obviously
that a lot of people were like well
that's not like the wendy in the book
and everything like that but honestly i
really think the casting was really good
i cannot imagine anybody else
in that role in that movie i mean she
just looked like her face just conveyed
so much
horror yeah and you know it's
because kubrick was [ __ ]
uh
abusing her on set that's why i mean he
put her through a lot of [ __ ] like to
get that out of her but
which is not good i'm not justifying it
but i mean
that is like an amazing performance and
to me that like makes it scarier because
she was so
because she was so cowed and she was so
submissive and it's like she had that
face where it's like you could just see
like all the terror on it and it was
just like it was so great it was so
great
um
oracle says jenny i'm re-reading a book
you might enjoy gideon the ninth which
has been described as lesbian
necromancers in space holy [ __ ] that
actually does sound really good
that sounds really good i'm gonna have
to like look that up i'm just like look
i even have like a pen and a little
pad of paper right here someone like
write it down
that sounds good i'm gonna get into that
let me get into that
all right let me write that down
lesbian necromancers in space
okay
i mean i know that's not what it's
called
uh oh looked it up it was not butterbean
oh okay it was a guy named peter bray
the guy was huge
yeah i was gonna say because i thought
by the time butterbean came around like
that
that would have been like way
dan michael said yeah interesting is a
perfect word for her that's what i like
yeah see i tend to like that kind of
thing too i like i said i like people
that are interesting looking
they you don't have to be like
conventionally attractive i just like
people that are interesting looking
you know what i mean
interesting give me something
interesting to look at
not just like a [ __ ]
perfect and [ __ ] like no well not
necessarily but maybe some people might
think it's ugly but it's like
and
wasn't ugly though she was kind of cute
yeah
well see that's what he was saying he's
like i always get that he always gets
picked on because no she was kind of
cute yeah she was kind of cute and like
i said she's [ __ ] great in the
shining i can't even imagine anyone else
they never show her made up either
yeah because she's supposed to
she's supposed to be kind of awkward
yeah
that's why they hire her well it's just
kind of like
yeah i mean everybody that's an actor
it's like everybody can't look like a
[ __ ] glamour puss because it's like
that's not always what the role calls
for you need character actors and that's
what they call them
which in a way is kind of like
i guess it's a backhanded compliment if
you're a character actor it's like well
you're not like good-looking enough to
be like a leading person but it's like
i don't know
that seems like what they mean by that
when they say character actor
just depends on whatever theatrical
um
traditions you're talking about like
china and korea see our movies and they
don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
they're like i didn't pay to see these
ugly [ __ ]
literally
that's what chinese people were saying
they should watch some british these
people are too [ __ ] ugly they should
watch the british movies sometime
because they actually legit just put
like regular ass looking people in their
movies which i always kind of which i
always liked the chinese don't don't
have that mentality at all
they're like this is a low quality movie
i paid to see
you know beautiful people and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] everybody in the goddamn movie
looks like a [ __ ] superstar that's
just that's just the way the chinese
see things that's probably goes back
that's their traditions and that's their
values you know
like uh
[Laughter]
they were on that midnight's edge there
it wasn't midnight says from what
channel it was
it might have been midnight my midnight
sets a bunch of
people that were like x industry and
then other people who are just fans fan
nerd fans
i said they had kind of leaked some
consumer [ __ ] feedback
from member uh from china
from the movie
the force awakens
it didn't do that well in the force
awakens
and disney wanted to know why it didn't
do that well
and the number one reason why the
chinese didn't like the movies they said
first of all they said the people were
ugly
people were ugly
and then uh they're not though but okay
they were talking about no if they
thought they were
i thought they were ugly
and uh they thought uh they didn't they
didn't have any idea why there was an
old man with a beard at the end there's
much [ __ ]
why are there old people there's people
in here yeah it's kind of like this is
like some logan's run [ __ ] that's the
one why they took that same poster
jenny i don't think jenny really knows
the full story about it no you told me i
know the poster john boyega they sunk
him all the way down because they didn't
want any black people on the planet
no china just [ __ ] you know they they
do what they want to do i'm just making
a joke about it and then now they
evidently [ __ ] uh don't want they
don't want any american movies anymore
i don't even know if they have it if
they're getting them now
whatever uh crybaby says sid haig or
michael berryman yeah see like people
like that
yeah like there's something kind of
compelling about it like michael
berryman's kind of like
he's kind of weird looking but it's he's
interesting looking sid hey
sid haig [ __ ] evolved into a scary
[ __ ] he was funny at the same
time especially though you should see
spider baby that was one that was a
movie that he was in like very very
young when he was really i was gonna say
that uh that one james cameron movie
that he was in when he was maybe 30.
yeah he was he was a cool looking dude
what was the name of the one
galaxy of terror yeah where he played
the dude in the crystals he only had a
few lives
yeah
yeah i always thought he was cool with
him
i mean i even think like people like
i even when i was growing up i was even
kind of into like we i was i don't know
i was like into weird-looking actors
like [ __ ] john malkovich and steve
buscemi and people like that it's like
which you know from some standpoint it's
like yeah they're not
good looking like in the traditional
sense but
and i think some of it has to do with
like their like the way they carry
themselves and stuff like that as well
because we've talked about this a lot
it's like
you don't necessarily have to look like
a [ __ ] fashion model
if you have like a really good
um
you know personality and you kind of
like have your own thing going on like
and you seem confident and you just like
whatever it is that you have going on
with your
you know with your looks or whatever you
just kind of own it then i think that
that's going to be a lot more attractive
than
yeah then somebody that's like super
good looking but is also a douchebag
well they're talking about they're
talking about bollywood they love that
shit's [ __ ] over the top too yeah if
you look at those bollywood movies first
of all they have to have a musical
[ __ ] act in every [ __ ] bollywood
movie well they it's like they have to
have something for everybody like every
single day every single day
and it has to be like three hours long
yeah
and uh
no that's that's another one where
[ __ ] like all of the young people
have to be [ __ ] like super good
looking
uh and then all the all the other
characters supporting characters are
real stereotypical
and yeah it's tedious [ __ ] bollywood
is [ __ ] tedious but
the best bali was with bollywood making
fun of bollywood that was fun there was
one of them that we saw remember that
horror movie i don't remember it was a
bollywood horror movie
and it was funny as [ __ ] too i just i
don't remember exactly oh i know what
one you're talking about it was over the
top and they were kind of
satirizing what we're talking about with
bollywood but i don't remember what it
was a long time ago we saw that one yeah
i remember i was worth seeing yeah
but it
it did all the [ __ ]
hollywood horror tropes and it knew it
was doing it and it pointed out that it
was copying hollywood horror movies it
was just [ __ ] funny and then it would
make reference to bollywood
just you know
well see i'm always kind of interested
because the thing about it is that
bollywood movies and stuff like that
like a lot of times like movies that you
see from other countries
um
are you don't see like everything
from those other countries you only just
generally see stuff that gets released
over here which are like bigger
productions or stuff that they think is
going to play over here
so
you don't always get like a good
representative
you know thing of like what all movies
they're making but the thing about it is
that
horror movies interestingly the horror
movies that i've seen from other
countries
i kind of feel like horror is almost
kind of like a universal
kind of thing because all the like
people all over the world are watching
american and british
european
horror movies so we all have the same
frame of reference so a lot of times
i'll see like horror movies from
you know from [ __ ] turkey or
something like that
but it still like has influences
that you would recognize you know what i
mean like i'm talking about like a while
back like i think 2015 or 2016 there's
this great great [ __ ] uh horror movie
i think it's turkish actually
that was called was it turkish it was
called baskin
and that's a fantastic movie and you can
tell that the guys that made that movie
were real into club barker
but they mixed it with
like zoroastrianism yeah like mythology
and there was also like it was kind of
surrealistic too so it was like a little
bit of like david lynch kind of action
going on there and it was [ __ ] great
it was a great [ __ ] movie i've seen
it like two or three times at this point
and it's like it just keeps it getting
better every single time i see it i
haven't seen it but yeah you might like
it actually it's weird as [ __ ] but it's
like i really dug it i really dug it
but um
dermott says nollywood is now a big
thing uh now a big thing too african
movie industry based mostly in nigeria
yeah yeah we used to watch the nigerian
movies on youtube yeah i mean that's a
few years ago but yeah yeah they were
doing it just for uh ad revenue you can
watch them for free
some they were they were kind of saving
me most of them
but some of them were funny
and they um
they were you know
they had a kind of christian themes
about possession and demons
uh terrible cg
but they were like kind of kind of fun
to watch you know in certain because
they were super fun you could see you
just you know they're probably making
the [ __ ] with just a phone but it was
you know just to show you what you can
do with no money no money but see that's
what i like about it that's why i always
cuz like i said i love horror movies and
i love seeing horror movies like
reinterpreted through other people's
cultures
like because like a lot of times like i
said they've seen the same horror movies
because everybody around the world has
seen like the [ __ ] exorcist and all
that kind of stuff like all the classics
and they all love that [ __ ] too but it's
kind of like filtered through their own
cultural context and i find that like
really fascinating one of the ones that
i thought was good was like a nigerian
gangster movie
and oh i know yeah all the guns were
fake yeah just see they just homemade
guns
they kind of look like guns though you
know
they're cg and they're using cgi to do
the [ __ ] uh i think he can do that in
after effects yeah
[Laughter]
to do the [ __ ] muzzle but he has like
the muzzle blaster
like their shot and
you know they're having a good time yeah
as long as you look like you're having a
good time and you're just like
that's kind of the thing that i'm
into like if if the movie doesn't have
to be that great
but if it was obviously made with a lot
of affection and they're having like a
good time doing it then i'll have a good
time watching it
you know what i mean you're making a
gangster movie
mr 88 said one notable nollywood movie
had a budget of 27 dollars
probably true probably true
um so they're talking about like indian
movies and then camp guy said uh i miss
living in atlanta we don't have squat
for indian food in chattanooga it's easy
to make that's a shame yeah and honestly
yeah once you like learn a couple of
like techniques of like making indian
food you can make pretty much anything
there's there's all kinds of indian
women on youtube showing you how to
execute those uh
um
recipes and a lot of indian women are
now using uh instapot
which man so many like cooking channels
i watch like they [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
yeah i bought one
and no inst an instant pot is [ __ ]
good to have
and they'll show you how to make all
those curries in an instant pot
and uh you know like chickpea curries
and all the different beans that they
will use
um just uh even even chicken kormas and
stuff you can do all that [ __ ] in an
instant pot
it's like a pressure i don't know what
that is it's a pressure cooker but you
can take the top off and you can also
turn it into a pot like a like yeah you
can use it for lots of others there's
different
yeah and you do it in a different order
but you can do it all in one pot and
within the rice on the side just cook
just when you [ __ ] with indian food
you want to use basmati rice you don't
don't use any [ __ ] american long
grain [ __ ] basmati is what they're
using
i mean i use racial work too but yeah
it's not as good yeah that's my tea is
that's the [ __ ] you want to use the
best one i've found comes in a burlap
and a burlap bag it's called royal
broil
and and i've asked second
indians what's the best rice the old
royal basmati royal that's their top
brand right there and it always comes
out perfect
always i haven't had a bad [ __ ] yeah
i don't know a lot of rice coming out
there it always comes and now what
they'll do is you take butter and put it
in the bottom of the pan and you put
your herbs in there bay leaf maybe
cardamom pod piece of a
piece of um
what do you call clove in there a
cinnamon stick and just saute it in
butter until it all starts releasing
that brown stuff and then pour that wet
soaked rice in there in the water bring
it to a cover it bring it to a boil turn
it down low or off
let it sit there 15 minutes or so when
you come back it'll be [ __ ]
beautiful rice
stir it
be kind of brown
that can go with anything
yeah i mean we're kind of lucky to have
really decent really decent indian
restaurants around here like my favorite
one is still memories of india
which is in lake mary
but there's also a good one called fifth
element yeah
i wonder if they started that buffet
back up
i don't know yeah they used to have a
buffet but it's like then during the
pandemic they didn't but this restaurant
was still open but they just didn't have
the buffet anymore but like i said
memories of india is still my favorite
they like the lamb korma they make is
[ __ ] out of this world that's what i
get like almost every time we go it's
either that or like shrimp masala i get
that too but and they make their own
mango ice cream which is fantastic i
don't even like mangoes and that ice
cream is one of the best things i've
ever eaten
but
once like i said we kind of figured out
well tom figured out like how to make
some of the stuff i don't think he's
ever replicated the lamb korma but he's
replicated like pretty much everything
else that they make at that restaurant
um you know
it takes a while but once you
once you know how to make like one or
two of the things like the methods are
pretty much the same like all that's
different is like you know maybe the
meat or the spice mixes
but they're mostly made like the same
kind of way
dan michael says indian food uh works
good with wheat bread too if you find
rice cooking to be a pain in the butt
like i do of course you buy this minute
rice cups that are actually pretty good
yeah i mean
we get the basmati rice in the big
burlap sack it's like a 20 pound bag
something like that i don't remember how
much it is but we usually get it at the
asian market
and
what you do
is it's two cups of rice
you soak it we put it in the cup like
two cups in the in the glass like pyrex
cup
then you soak it for a little while
and then you pour it into the pot
it's two cups of rice
and
three cups of water oh what
making the making the rice for basmati
yeah you gotta pre-soak the yeah i said
that pre-soak it and then strain it um
two cups
two cups of rice
two and a half two and a half inches or
three cups three three that's what i see
yeah okay three cups three cups of rice
and then you and three cups let it come
to a boil put it on the thing like with
the lid on it
when it comes to a boil like when it
comes boiling out just take it off the
heat but that's it yeah just just let it
sit 15 minutes let it sit for 15 minutes
and it comes out like perfect every
single time that's all you got to do all
you got to do thank you for bringing
this up i just remember something what's
that
i'm going to plant some curry leaves
because now i can plant them you should
because we can't always get them like
sometimes they're growing around
sometimes they have them at the indian
store and sometimes they don't right and
they're fresh which means they can grow
here yeah but i'll plant that bush that
makes them curry leaves and if they just
take you get a string of that [ __ ] and
pull them [ __ ] leaves like that put
that in your curry
it makes a huge difference yeah it's
almost kind of like
almondy taste weird
well we got them a few times when they
had them because the the indian market
we used to go to like she grew them and
she would bring them in sometimes like
in bundles and she'd have them behind
them she'd have them in big plastic bags
like behind the counter do you want some
curry leaves yeah
yeah she got some from her garden but
they didn't have them all the time right
because we added them to a few of the
recipes i'm like god hot damn that's
like really good because sometimes when
you go to memories of india like they
put curry leaves like in a lot of their
stuff and i'm like man this shit's
really good but they didn't always have
it at the indian market it was very hit
or miss you can get them dry but they're
better fresh yeah they're much better
fresh so yeah we should totally like
grow around that that would be a lot
better some kind of bush i got to look
to see whether it was some kind of bush
yeah grandma's all about bush
not anymore right now
but
not for several years all right but uh
granthar said spicy goat vindaloo yeah
that's good yeah honestly i like i know
and goats are super cute so i'm kind of
like conflicted about their family yeah
but
i mean their their meat is they taste
good though they do taste good yeah
sorry goats y'all are cute and
everything they don't know what him i
mean pigs are cute too yeah and i also
eat pigs so and also cows are cute and i
also eat cows so
i mean [ __ ]
this is a great place for a [ __ ]
rabbit
pen
but like i said i don't want to kill
rabbits no
because then you re-raise them and
they're very they're friendly they're
like little cats like i said like
killing a cat
i'd have to be really you would probably
be like look it's a little bunny friend
yeah so how do i want to get into the
our friend angel grows them
um you know i mean he kills them [ __ ]
bust their little [ __ ] heads off yeah
i'm not that cold-blooded sorry yeah
i got no problems with chickens and
[ __ ] fish and [ __ ] like that but
[ __ ] i can do fish but i think i
still think i'd have problems with
chickens but there's too much like a cat
that's absolutely no way i could do
bunnies no way
i can't even watch like fake animals get
killed in movies i get upset
to be honest or do you guys remember
like a few months back and i reviewed
that dario argenti movie trauma
and there's a scene in that where a kid
squishes a tokay gekko
i couldn't even watch that
he what he squished like a tokai gekko
yeah
and i was like i used to have one of
those for a pet yeah i'm like yeah i had
to skip that scene i can't watch it i
can't watch it and like i said i can't
watch like
i can watch people get killed in movies
all day long i don't give a [ __ ] about
people but it's like when they start
doing stuff to kitties and doggies and
yeah mystery yeah we i saw a world
police that was yeah i didn't see it
okay it was good it was funny yeah
michael schaefer said didn't bush go out
of style in the 70s it might have been
was it the 70s or the 80s i feel like uh
well no 80s i'm talking about porn yeah
i think like 80s porn you started seeing
it like like phasing out phasing out and
[ __ ] huge implants
that was very that was when you started
and 90s was mega implants then you deal
with like tiffany towers and that that
those girls
wonder if they still have those big
boobs no they never if they yeah they're
still yeah because they probably got
like sick of that [ __ ] like i said well
uh tiffany towers uh [ __ ]
got smaller ones after that and then she
retired
because they're still big though like i
said if you just get it for porn it's
just kind of like like i said that's
like carrying around two like [ __ ]
luggage on your chest that you can't
ever like take off at the end of the day
end of the work day they're
they were like our friends there that do
the [ __ ] cam stuff with the [ __ ]
yeah i know
they like them but it's it's fetish
yeah and uh
you know i guess
i
in terms of the the girls i think in the
90s the professional ones i don't think
they were doing it so much for fetish
reasons just for the money
and then it kind of went out of style
you know
that attracts a lot of attention
so
and it doesn't look that good in clothes
if you see what those girls look like in
regular clothes they all look kind of
fat even they're [ __ ] skinny that's
what i'm saying because that hangs right
on them that's another thing is that you
can't find clothes that fit and the
clothes that fit you have to buy
everything like several sizes bigger
than you would normally wear and then
things have to be [ __ ] tailored so
the [ __ ] shirts swing underneath the
[ __ ] boobs so it doesn't look like
you're pregnant yeah you know and then
that that's all let's see how that could
get right right so they have to get
really tired
skin tight [ __ ] as you know
but you know [ __ ]
um
the two girls that we're talking about i
don't want to [ __ ] mention their
names or anything
but they not like that ever stopped you
before
[Laughter]
they wear clothes they're like that they
they're into that
it's the same thing as like you know
dudes that [ __ ]
get freaky big on [ __ ] steroids
that's also kind of a fetish [ __ ]
weird body dysmorphic yeah up to it yeah
up to a point and like i said i'm a big
advocate of like look whatever you want
to do with your body if you want to like
tattoo yourself with snake scales and
like split your tongue and stuff like
that more power to you
it's not my body i don't give a i don't
really care do that i mean i wouldn't do
it but if you want to do it if that's
really what you want to do then go for
it i'm not going to like do it and i'm
not going to like [ __ ] judge you or
stare at you or nothing like this do you
do you
um everybody's different
but i'm just saying like for me it just
seems like a lot of that kind of stuff
like i said these [ __ ] big giant and
i'm talking about like giant like beach
ball kind of tits
that's kind of like
to me that just seems like a [ __ ]
god that just seems like it'd be such a
pain in the ass it would just be like
you couldn't find any clothes that fit
everything would be just like your back
would hurt your shoulders would hurt
like constantly like i said you wouldn't
be able to take it off you couldn't see
your feet you couldn't like bend over it
just seems like it would be like too
much
it's just too much
the the
the only one that's kind of like that
now it still would be like penelope
black diamond you guys can look her up
she's a german
uh entertainer
and she's kind of like goth fetish
type
and she's skinny
[ __ ] huge implants
she wears skin tight stuff and it's
tailored for that but which it looks
good on her but the thing is is that no
matter what she does she looks like a
porn star
that's what i mean and like that's
another thing you can't like go anywhere
and have like a normal life yeah because
everyone's just gonna stare at you or
harass you or something like that oh
they won't harass you depending on well
depends on where you go oh i don't think
and her boyfriend's [ __ ] huge
yeah but she maybe has to go places by
herself sometimes it's like look i i
don't know if you've ever been a woman
in your life but
you go somewhere with boobs that are
kind of like just over a little bit over
the average you're going to get harassed
i'm sorry but that's just what's going
on that's germany so i don't know if
it's that bad in germany it might be
they might be i don't know i'm just i
can't speak for germany i've never been
there but i'm just saying that
most other places i've ever been yeah
that's gonna happen and especially if
it's like so
big that it's like it's really really
noticeable so that's kind of the thing
it's like so you really have to kind of
weigh
like how much because you think to
yourself well
it's like a fetish but like you know
people you're only seeing her for
however long it takes you to jack off
right but it's like she has to live like
that like 24 7. get us banned you know
what i mean
we've said way worse than that on this
channel and we're still here so i'm not
worried about it but um and most of our
[ __ ] doesn't even get demonetized so
they don't even the only time the only
time that we get demonetized is usually
when we talk about like really [ __ ] up
serial killers then that way they'll be
like oh limited ads but that's pretty
much the worst i don't think i've ever
had anything completely demonetized
that's that's
yeah but it's like like i said
yeah i mean that's pretty i mean you're
whiting everything out but yeah okay
that's who we're talking about
that's [ __ ] huge
yeah and like i said just to me that
just seems like [ __ ] a back problem
waiting to happen but like i said i'm
not here to like judge other people's
but she wants to like be like that all
the time that's fine but like i said
you know you see like you see or you
just see pictures or you just see porn
of her or something like that like over
here
like that all the time that's what i
mean over like a short period of time
she's got to live like that all the time
yeah i can't sleep on my stomach i can't
go out anywhere without people [ __ ]
but you know what i mean it's looking at
her toenails though i think for me it
just seems like that would be too much
trouble just too much trouble looking at
her toenails i think that girl's just
like that she's [ __ ] toenails [ __ ]
four inches long curling over which like
i said like i don't know i'm just i'm
just talking about yeah and some people
are and like i said
i'm just saying
if you want to like get plastic surgery
and make yourself look like a lion yeah
okay
what
it doesn't like it doesn't hurt me any
so why the [ __ ] should i care do what
you want do what you want but
i'm just saying for me
that would just be like way too much you
have to look like that all the time
that's what i mean that would be like
way too much yeah
you have to walk around like that
because you put clothes on her and all
of a sudden she's gonna look crazy she
looks yeah she's going to look crazy but
she looks kind of normal like that i
mean you look good when you have really
skimpy clothes right but then you put it
it's like when you put normal clothes on
you go look fat you're going to look fat
or you're going to look like weird yeah
which is the first thing that i would
think of right to me like i said it just
seems like too much trouble yeah seems
like too much trouble
so you know
dan michael said back in the 70s and 80s
you still had male designers making
jeans for girls women started looking
better when the female designers took
over i still think nothing looks better
than a dress yeah i mean depends on like
i said a lot of things depend on the
body style because everything everybody
has a different body style and different
body styles look good in different
things
i've tend to found to tend to find what
i look
best in
i think
is stuff that's cut like
50s style you know what i
mean yeah where it's just kind of like
i don't know
you know what i mean you look good in a
lot of stuff though just all depends i
know but i'm just saying my favorite
stuff that's why i've always been kind
of more drawn to like kind of
rockabilly kind of styles because i like
that kind of like 50s retro
kind of look
i feel like that looks better on me
but
everybody is different so
different [ __ ] looks better on different
people
but the thing about jeans though is just
kind of like i don't know whose idea it
was in the 80s
some idiot's idea
in the 80s let's make all the genes
super high wasted
so it'll make every single chick that
wears them look pregnant and also have a
flat ass yeah i don't know why that
happened somebody's asking why you
soaked the rice no you soaked the rice
because
some types of rice need
um
if you didn't soak the rice and then
cooked it at the normal cooking time it
would come out be hard
so what you're doing is you're soaking
it to try to get some water
down through the husks
now
soak the rice but then you drain the
water out of the rice you run it through
it you have it you're going through like
a sieve it's like a
yeah it's like a sieve and then you're
throwing that
wet rice into a hot pan it's got butter
on it
and you're using a rubber spatula and
you're kind of
frying that hard rice for
like a minute
and you're breaking down the outer husk
and then you pour the water in it and
it'll come out a lot tender a lot better
a lot tender kind of
it'll it'll have
substance to it but it
it'll be um still kind of fluffy
that's my tea would be hard if you
didn't pre-soak it
and i don't think you don't really have
to soak it for that long time i've seen
some like things that say
oh soak it for half an hour or an hour
you don't necessarily have to soak it
that long we usually only soak it for
like five minutes yeah i've forgotten it
before and come back about a half hour
later and it comes back kind of mushy
it's too soft
after you cook it we usually took it
what about five minutes about a minute
not even okay about a minute and a half
two minutes but you should soak it
you can look and see like warm water you
can see that
it starts the the rice
pieces of rice start off white and then
they slowly kind of get clear around the
edges and then you know about a minute
later and you see that some of the
centers of them have kind of gone clear
it's time to go then cook them
drain the water out and cook it
fry it to kind of [ __ ]
when it goes in that hot pan you have
butter in the bottom of it hot butter
you can and in the butter you can have
spices or just butter
i like to have just butter you can use
oil too
drop the wet rice into that oil or
butter it'll start sputtering and
popping and then you just use a rubber
spatula just kind of keep folding it
for 30 seconds or a minute and that'll
kind of break down the outer husk of the
rice pour the water in and cover it
reaches a boil take it off the water
take it off the fire yeah that's all you
got to do it's like yeah two i think
it's it'll boil over as soon as it boils
over just yeah as soon as it comes out
like from the sides of the of the lid
yeah then just push it off yeah that's
it just push it off and just let it sit
there let it sit like tea it'll sit
there and steep yeah
and then after like 10-15 minutes it'll
be it'll be perfect and we do it like
that and it just comes out perfect every
single time it never comes out [ __ ] up
dan michael said um oh wait a minute mr
88 said you know what fashion trend i
don't know why it happened everything in
the 70s yeah pretty much uh no there
were hot clothes in the 70s it's just
well depended on you had to be like a
skinny coconut you had to be skinny and
you had
you had to be sexy and um you had to uh
know what to buy and what not to buy you
had to know how to combine it
they had somewhat girls knew how to
dress from that
i have a lot of cool [ __ ] from the 70s a
lot of the problems with the 70s [ __ ] is
that you got a girl trying to try to
wear
the wrong combination of [ __ ] and it
just that just doesn't [ __ ] work
and there was also a difference between
white fashion and black fashion the
pants that black girls were wearing were
a lot better than the pants the white
girls were wearing well gotta say you
watched some black exploitation movies
in the 70s the fashion's way better yeah
the black fashion was what the white
people were wearing
not so much the bell bottoms that white
girls wore were high-waisted
all right and the bell
went up past the knee and slowly tapered
up to the [ __ ]
crotch
so you didn't have a flare at the bottom
the black girls wore
low like hip huggers they were tight
around the uh the uh the thigh and then
at the knee it flared out
most some white girls wore those but
mostly black girls wore those and those
looked a lot better
the uh the average [ __ ] the white girls
were wearing was that the cut was wrong
it was not flattering at all well like i
said just like well i kind of feel like
this is true of fashion of every era
yeah
um
unless you are
really skinny
you really i mean most of the [ __ ]
doesn't look good on you then in the 70s
that for real was true like if you were
really really scrawny
then yeah some of that [ __ ] might look
good on you anybody else if you had like
any little bit of weight or if you were
normal size or anything like that that
[ __ ] wasn't gonna look good yeah but i
think on earlier episodes i even busted
out photos and showed what i was talking
about photos from the 70s
and just
the average [ __ ] that
white girls were wearing in the 70s it
just pictures the girls walking around
it was just
it was not good selection they didn't
know how to select for what they had in
it and the cuts that they were using you
say well that's bell bottoms
no they're not the belt when you say
bell bottoms today it's like a hip
huggers tight around the thigh and it
starts to bell right after the the knee
that's the typical
iconic bell bottom
the thing is is that that particular
bell bottle is what black girls were
wearing white girls for the most part
didn't wear those they were a different
cut of it and it wasn't as good
and it was high waisted not low wasted
so just
and then it was a skinny girl wearing
this [ __ ] and then right above the waist
it went past the belly button then she'd
wear like a tube top so there's about a
an inch an inch of [ __ ] skin going
around flesh and then right above that
would be like
some kind of [ __ ]
uh tube top or uh what do you call it um
a uh
like a uh like a bikini top thing but it
just didn't look good at all well the
thing about tube tops and things like
that
the thing about tube tops yeah was that
i think those really probably only
looked good on real flat chester real
small chested women because you had
anything like a little bit larger than
the ship was going to sag
and you didn't really have any structure
there was no structure in the tube top
they will only look
good i'm going to disagree they didn't
even look good on flat chested women
they well no i'm saying if they looked
good that was the only person those two
tops only looked good
on real young girls that were had real
like big but hard boobs or a girl that
had [ __ ] implants and people don't
realize how how how many implants were
out there especially in the california
era
implants were [ __ ] common in the 70s
but see that's kind of what we're saying
you needed like because a tube top you
couldn't wear a bra with it it couldn't
yeah your bra
so you needed to have some support so
you either had to be flat-chested or you
had to have implants or you had to be
genetically gifted and young
and that didn't last until i had like
perky tits and yeah like i said once
you're in like your 20s or 30s yeah
shit's gonna start to sag and the [ __ ]
and i've seen some movies yeah i've seen
movies with like girls that had tube
tops on in the 70s and like yeah shit's
kind of like sagging like down there it
just doesn't look good it doesn't look
good people don't realize that i've said
implants they weren't even implants a
lot of it was silicone infusion
the whole thing about
putting silicone or saline in an implant
bag and having that inside of a woman's
chest was kind of a newer thing i think
that was actually more very late 70s
early 80s that they came out with that
before that era i think they just
[ __ ] took a big medical silicone in a
damn iv bag or a syringe and just
injected it right in right into the uh
into the breast that's how it was done
in japan going back to the late 40s
early 50s
they were the ones that invented breast
implants or saline injection and with
saline not saying excuse me a silicone
it was silicone
was cheap
and as long as it was sterile
they seemingly could mostly get away
with it
but you couldn't do it in the united
states because there was a failure rate
and some women didn't would
would have allergic reactions to that
sometimes fatal
so fda wouldn't allow that
but they did that in japan for a long
time and and then when i was living in
brazil
most of your most of your
[ __ ] i'm going to say professional
women of the evening
were silicone infusion
and it wasn't even [ __ ] medical
silicone they were using industrial
silicone just injecting it with a
syringe probably not the best idea no
not a good idea well they would try to
heat it up to [ __ ] kill bacteria that
was in it
but still man
that was never intended to be in a human
being i mean you don't know what kind of
container that's doing you don't know
what kind of container that was stored
in what was gasoline that's what i mean
also in that and and heating it wouldn't
get it that wouldn't get those temples
out of there you don't know there's you
don't know what what kind of container
you don't know what the provenance of
that is right and uh
people have said well that'll get into
the bloodstream i've i've heard doctors
fight over [ __ ] online
about it and they were saying that well
what usually happened with the implants
is the silicone implants is that
eventually the silicone implant ruptured
anyway
but the silicone was still trapped in
place it was better than saline because
it was trapped in place
and because it couldn't penetrate the
scar tissue that formed around an
implant so the
so really what was containing it was not
the implant the scar tissue was was
contained in it
and they said that was the same thing
that would happen with just injecting it
straight in it just formed a scar around
it that contained it into it
and the japanese did it for a long time
but like i said that's medical silicone
do not do that
i mean i would like to think that we
wouldn't have to say that yeah but not
yeah
but they got girls here that have gotten
in trouble using the silicone tire
sealant injecting that into their asses
those girls from brazil [ __ ] doing it
to women here i mean how [ __ ]
desperate do you have to be like to have
like a bigger ass it works
but it ends up having basically a big
old knot like a rubber like like the
[ __ ] end of an eraser you know you're
building an implant
you touch it it would probably just i
don't want a big feel like a [ __ ] and
then you got to sit on that
that's what i mean like i said you have
to think like
you know however why ever the reason
you're doing because some man told you
to look good or whatever it's like you
got to live with that [ __ ] 24 7.
yeah well they're making you have to
live with your entire life they tend to
be strippers and [ __ ] prostitutes
right but that's just your job like i
said when you're not on the job you
still have to have that you can't just
like it's not like like some foxy fetish
clothes or like uncomfortable boots that
you can just take off at the end of the
night this is something that is in your
body and there's also there's also some
there are also girls out there that just
uh
you know have uh uh you know
booty greed
that you know it's kind of like some
girls have boob greed other ones have
booty greed that their their booty has
to be big that bigger than their
friend's booty
and this is mostly you know i never
really looked that hard at my friend's
booties well this is mostly
african-american uh girls doing this and
they want a big old booty so they're
[ __ ] the brazilian girls [ __ ]
showing up with
silicone tire sealant i mean silicone
tire sealant they [ __ ] make an
apparatus with a [ __ ] large gauge
needle on it and now put that up in the
booty like that and i'll [ __ ] do it
in a pump silicone tire sealant
into a woman's ass you stay just like
that for six hours and she's sitting on
her [ __ ] belly for six hours letting
that [ __ ] dry
no thanks
yeah and then give me 500 and then i
mean like maybe i'm old fashioned but
yeah i mean i like my girlfriends just
for their like personalities
you know what i mean i just like them
because they're cool like they're cool
to hang out with i've honestly never
really launched their butts all that
closely
you know what i mean just just never
have
um
let me see uh mr idiot said the worst
style thing from the 70s was oily skin
check out any movie from that decade see
i kind of wonder i have wondered about
this too
i don't
actually know i wonder if it was just
because
oh we're gonna have oily skin because
that's more natural
or if it was just because they had
shitty makeup
for movies back then
was i don't know like i can't really
decide if it's one or the other because
it could be is like particularly like
movies that were
lower budget
it could be just that they didn't really
have a budget or they you know they
didn't have the right lighting or they
didn't have like a professional makeup
artist or something like that where it's
just kind of like hey we gotta get in
there and like powder her [ __ ] face
down because she's like super shiny
i don't really know i don't really know
i've always been i remember like from a
very young age i really do not like
being shiny and it's really really hard
not being shiny like in florida because
this [ __ ] place man that's like so
humid you're gonna like switch your ass
off so you really have to like
just i have to have powder like wherever
i go just powder powder powder whatever
like all the time because otherwise
you're gonna be like super shiny
mr eddie it says poor women all the crap
men put you through for something as
frivolous as breast size yeah tell me
about it it's just kind of like
i don't know i'm getting to a point now
where i'm probably too old for that [ __ ]
but
i'm too old for this [ __ ] just like in
lethal weapon but um
you know or whatever but it's just kind
of like
i don't know i feel like women do it to
themselves too you know what i mean i
don't think it's just dudes but
i think women do it to themselves
because they want to look better than
other women
but i guess that's also down to men well
that's also down to men we i want to
look better for to i don't think so no
it is i don't i'm not getting bigger for
men i'm not doing no way i'm not getting
bigger for women but no one's talking
about you though women women no we're
talking about women we're not talking
about men women do it for their own for
their the women are doing it the ones
that are going through all that because
i saw programs on it
it's all [ __ ] self-esteem they want
to [ __ ] feel but like i said
self-esteem
for some women comes from
quote-unquote men think i'm attractive
so
so you could go back to that too you're
blaming me no i'm not i'm just saying
men don't have anything to do with
anorexia women are [ __ ] have
self-esteem and anorexia because they're
anorexics
well yeah well that's anorexic anorexia
is not usually and like i said i i know
someone no it's not though exactly
because my fam someone in my family had
anorexia
anorexia is not necessarily what they
look like anorexia is a control issue
yeah anorexia is good i'm um i live in a
in a world where i don't have any
control over my own life and the only
thing i control is what i eat like what
i put in my body okay so a lot of times
like what they
so them not eating and them like losing
weight and being skinny like that it's
not so much what they look like okay
even though they do kind of have a
little bit of body dysmorphia
where they where she thinks you know she
looks bigger than she is but
usually it's a control issue it's
somebody that is like their parents are
like super controlling or really strict
or
they have some kind of like personality
thing where they feel like they have to
be perfect or it's like it's a
controller and i think it's the same
thing it's a controllability and then
i'm gonna i'm gonna agree with w
with other my other sources
in the bodybuilding community that
anorexia and bigorexia are about the
[ __ ] same thing bigorexia is just a
word we made up [ __ ] just can't
get any bigger you know what i mean but
he wants to be bigger than that
yeah i mean and it's just like it is a
mental problem
yeah and like i said and like i said i
wasn't even talking and i mean you went
off on like bodybuilding i wasn't
talking about that and honestly i think
that that's probably the same thing as
anorexia because like i said
it's a control issue right but it
doesn't have anything to do with
attractiveness necessarily i okay well i
don't i don't think i don't think i
think that's well let's i've said that i
said i think it has more than about
feeling better about themselves
some about the way that they feel when
they look and i think
anorexia bigorexia and those girls that
are just [ __ ] have boob super high
amounts of boob greed super high amounts
of booty greed i think it's all about
the same i think it's all about the same
thing and it's kind of like the same
kind of deal as it
forces people to do body mods
i can they're body mods out there but
man some people just cannot stop getting
tattoos some people can't stop cutting
pieces of themselves off
you know i mean dudes that want to
[ __ ] amputate legs
you know i mean yeah
it's like that
it's like well like i said i don't think
like that like i mean to that point like
like i said people that are that extreme
yeah i don't think it's about just
quote-unquote attractiveness anymore i
mean what we were talking about
previously like before you came in was
just kind of like just general
attractiveness kind of stuff what we're
talking about here like with anorexia or
people that you know do extreme body
modification that's usually a different
thing like i said anorexia bigorexia
that kind of stuff that's usually a
control issue that comes from
some some other mental issues that they
have and honestly people that are
that get into a thing where they do like
these extreme body mods or like they
can't stop doing body mods that is
usually a symptom of like an addictive
personality right okay and sometimes
they have other addictions there's going
to be a bunch of that go along yeah and
sometimes like i said i'm not a
psychiatrist but that sometimes there's
like a lot of crossover with some other
addiction like that behavior that german
porn star that i showed you there that
[ __ ]
your first reaction was that she's doing
that for guys and i said well it's
partly her job but i don't think it has
anything to do with that because if you
look at the other stuff that she's into
it's a fetish well like i said i didn't
say that
i didn't say that about her in
particular i don't know her yeah she
evidently [ __ ] loves looking like
that
but like i said that and like i said
more power too like some people do and
like i said i'm not judging like if
people want to do that legitimately and
they're just kind of like hey i'm into
this and i want to and i know that i
have to live with this like 24 7 blah
blah blah then [ __ ] like do it like i
said it's your body that girl's just a
straight-up fetishist it's your body but
like i said she grew her toenails out
about two inches
is it just because she couldn't see them
to clip them no they're curved
they curled down i kid i kid so when she
puts those [ __ ] platforms on the
[ __ ] toenails go down the [ __ ]
front of the [ __ ] platform i would
think that you would be grossed out by
that it was gross yeah yeah yeah
you're a very grossed out yeah we thomas
is very grossed out but we're weird
looking i think it's really weird
looking thomas gross out by feet yeah
really weird looking i mean unless
you're a foot fetishist i think most
people are mildly grossed out by you
because feet are really usually not that
attractive unless you're into that
unless you're quentin tarantino but like
well she has nice feet as far as feet go
but the [ __ ] nails are just looking
like out of the way what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah
well like i said if you if that's your
issue if you're into that yeah then like
i said and i'm not saying like across
the board that like every woman that
takes forethought that gets like super
huge implants or something like that i'm
just saying that personally for me
that's all i said was they are fake but
they look real to me
they might be press-ons
can you even buy like fake super long
like i don't know press on they look
real to me they look really i have never
seen press-on i'm sure they sell them
somewhere i'm sure there's like some
kind of like
because i've learned that pretty much
anything that i can think of as [ __ ]
up as it is somebody is selling it
somewhere and somebody's buying it
i know there's press on nails because i
have those but press on toenails never
thought about it okay well never thought
about it i'm gonna uh let's go ahead and
start uh moving the show along it's
almost time for us to start getting
ready yeah i gotta start we gotta start
getting ready to go
because we gotta go about nine thirty
and it was eight thirty eight yeah we
still got like a little bit less than an
hour thank you guys for uh hanging out
with us before we go to the club we're
pre-gaming with us you guys have a nice
night this is a friday night have fun on
the weekend
and uh we'll see you guys when uh sunday
sunday evening we'll probably be talking
about the untouchables okay yeah because
like i said right here louie sells this
movie so we'll probably watch it
tomorrow night and do a review of it on
sunday
so have a good weekend everybody and we
will see you guys again on sunday